Some bus,
seventh,
19,
41,
a date which will live in infamy.
Perfect.
Leah events.
The figure is from this time and place I
take pride in being the Alina tear down
drama.
Welcome.
This kind of examination,
whether or not their president said,
well,
I'm not a crop.
If we dig deep in our district and our
doctrine don't remember,
but we are not descended from fearful of
man.
It's hardcore history.
I remember a conversation I had quite a
long time ago now with an author of a
book.
The author had written a book about how
John F Kennedy was assassinated by Lee
Harvey Oswald,
just like the government always said it
happened
and I had been asking him a bunch of
questions about conspiracies and you
know this or that aspect of the Kennedy
assassination and only one of his
answers in a really stands out in my
mind now because it seems irrelevant on
so many different fronts.
One of the answers on why it was so hard
for some people to accept what this guy
was purporting as the truth he said,
was because people are inherently very
uncomfortable with the idea that a
single nobody can have such an effect on
all of our lives.
It's more comforting.
He said to believe that powerful,
you know,
groups of people or conspiracies are
actually running things.
Even if you think those powerful groups
are nefarious,
it's somehow comforting to think that
somebody is in charge.
That it's not all just random number,
that a plane couldn't just drop from the
sky and land on your house tomorrow.
And I thought about this when I was
thinking about know someone,
if somebody had asked you a question,
who was the most important figure in the
past hundred years in terms of why the
world has gone the way it did?
You know,
you would think of all these famous
people whose names almost anyone who's a
halfway educated would recognize.
And yet,
what's interesting is you could
conceivably put the name down of
somebody who was historically speaking,
you know,
uh,
nobody,
Lee Harvey Oswald on the pages of the
history books besides the Kennedy
assassination,
is a nobody,
he didn't do anything else of
importance,
but that event was huge,
right?
If he actually killed John F Kennedy,
the way the narrative says,
Lee Harvey Oswald changed the world,
he changed the president instantly,
right?
I mean,
how many of us have the potential to
change who the president of the United
States is that lone gunman did,
if he was indeed the lone gunman,
the person who may be most responsible
for the modern world,
this entire world,
including the nine slash 11 attacks that
you know,
many commentators say,
shaped the modern world,
right?
We live in an era of terrorism or the
age of terrorism.
You'll hear them say without them
seeming to really understand that the
age of terrorism supposedly sparked by
the nine slash 11 attacks and the very,
very,
very early 21st century or themselves
manifestations of an act of terrorism
that launched us into the 20th century.
If we actually live in an age of
terrorism,
as some of these people like to say,
we've been living in it for more than
100 years,
I think you could make the case that the
most important individual in the last
century is Gavrilo,
Princip and Gavrilo.
Princip is a name.
Very few of you will recognize.
How can a person have so little
achievement in on the world.
Stage B perhaps credited with creating
the entire world around us.
I mean if,
if Gavrilo Princip doesn't live,
is there a nine slash 11 attack ever,
and if that was all he did,
wouldn't he be important you a lot more
than that.
Get principles.
The reason there was a second world war
because Gavrilo Princip is the reason
there was a first
and to be fair to principal,
if you could have gone to him and shown
him the ramifications of what that one
day a week due to the world,
I think he'd be horrified.
He wasn't trying to unleash a global
world war.
He just became the latest example of
someone pulling the trigger in a giant
historical game of Russian roulette.
A trigger that had been pulled several
times already with nothing happening.
Who would have thought that the time
that prince it pulled it,
that would be the time that the
metaphorical revolver pointed at the
skull of the old world,
shot a bullet into its brain.
Perhaps Princip in his compatriots would
have thought that you know sometimes
when you're trying to create a new
world,
you have to utterly destroy the old one
and the people in that old world.
We're not naive about the potential for
someone like a principal to do what they
did.
I mean Otto von Bismarck,
one of the greatest diplomats of 19th
century Europe,
perhaps the greatest diplomat,
Germany ever produced,
famously said that if there was going to
be some giant global conflict,
it was going to probably break out
because of some damn fool event in the
Balkans.
Governor Lowe Princip shot two people in
the city of Sarajevo smack dab in the
Balkans.
A place that Otto von Bismarck had
famously said was not worth the bones of
a single Pomeranian Grenna dear.
It would cost a hell of a lot more than
that and prince,
it becomes yet another example in
history proving to us that sometimes
when it comes to something like
terrorism in this era,
by the way,
when we tried desperately to keep
weapons of mass destruction out of the
terrorist hands because we're afraid
they'll be able to kill more people with
such weapons.
We forget that sometimes.
It's not about how many people you kill.
Sometimes it's about who they are and
often it's not the terrorist act that
changes the world.
It's the response of the victims,
you know,
that does Gov reload.
Princip killed two people and he did so
in a way that almost makes you believe
in fate
and truthfully,
I'm not much of a faith believer,
but one of the things I like about
history is how it forces me to challenge
some of my own preconceptions and
certainly make me think about other
possibilities.
I've always thought,
for example,
that history unfolds for chaotic
reasons.
We that it's somewhat random that
millions of people going about their
lives and their own ways with trends and
forces acting upon them and people in
important positions making decisions and
all of this together creates a dynamic
that's completely unpredictable.
As I said,
somewhat chaotic and random and unfolds
into the future.
I think my logical side of the brain
appreciates that sort of viewpoint.
The problem is is that sometimes history
confronts us with events where the
logical part of,
at least my brain wants to flip sides
and wants to logically defend what I
consider to be the more illogical point
of view.
In this case,
the logical part of my brain will
sometimes shift and try to defend
something like fate or destiny or
predetermination.
Those to me are the two ends of the
scale chaos on one side and randomness
on one side and fate and predestination
on the other,
and there's this weird twilight zone
where the two sort of intersect and that
event that happened in late June.
Nineteen 14 is one of the best examples
you'll find from history where you know
the.
The logical side of your brain stands a
pretty good chance of flipping and
trying to defend the illogical position
that this is somehow predestined.
I mean,
let me challenge you with a similar kind
of analogy.
Assumingly Harvey Oswald did kill
President Kennedy.
What if someone showed up right when he
had the rifle and he was aiming at in
the room where he was forcing him to
sort of Scotch.
The whole thing screwed up.
The whole assassination attempt at the
last minute,
you know,
Oswald's storms out of the Texas book
depository,
angry that is well laid.
Plans have been destroyed and he goes
across town to his favorite restaurant
and he goes and he gets himself a bite
to eat and when he's coming out of the
restaurant,
angry at how his day has gone right in
front of him.
Within five or six feet,
stopped below him.
Is John F Kennedy's car with Kennedy in
it close to Oswald and on the far side
of the president,
his wife Jackie.
What are the odds of something like that
happening?
What would you think if it did?
Just a weird coincidence,
Huh?
On June 28th,
19,
14,
Gavrilo Princip and about 20 other guys.
This is a true conspiracy show up in the
city of Sarajevo with murder on their
minds.
They want to kill the the governing
figure.
I'm in Sarajevo.
The person who is sort of the Prince
Charles plays the same role.
Prince Charles plays in the British
monarchy right now in the monarchy of
the country that are the overlords in
Sarajevo country that doesn't exist
anymore.
Called Austria.
Hungary and Austria.
Hungary is led by a really old,
very well loved guy named Franz Joseph
who's going to die soon because he's
very old and the person who will take
over when Franz Joseph dies is this guy
coming on a visit to Siri,
afo the Prince Charles of his country.
Although unlike Prince Charles,
who's role is completely ceremonial,
this guy will actually have some real
power when he gets the throne and for
some you know now when you look back on
it looks like a stupid reason.
This guy whose name is archduke Franz
Ferdinand,
has decided to go to Sarajevo and watch
military maneuvers which happened to
coincide with the anniversary of the
most emotionally important,
heart wrenching,
you know,
battlefield lost in all Serb history,
the battle of Kosovo way back from
hundreds and hundreds of years before
this time period.
Certain nationalists and the Serbs are
very,
very patriotic.
Even today,
even more so back in 1914.
Look at this as a slap in the face to
them,
sorry.
A Vo is Slavic and should be part of at
least a Pan Slavic country or maybe part
of Serbia.
There had been Balkan wars for the last
decade,
you know,
concerned with many of these
nationalistic questions who should own
these areas and it had been in the hands
of the Ottoman Turks who the slavs
definitely feel,
shouldn't have been running the place.
And it was transferred to the hands of
the Austria Hungarian empire,
which the Serb nationalists still don't
feel should be running the place.
And now the archduke was coming on the
anniversary of this historic defeat.
You know from the Serb nationalist
viewpoint to rub their nose in the fact
that Siri,
Eva was still held by a big non slavic
empire
and they're going to make Franz
Ferdinand pay for that and in the
remarkably similar situation to the
Kennedy assassination,
Ferdinand's route for his motorcade is
published ahead of time.
He's going to be arriving and going down
the main boulevards in an open car with
his wife sitting next to him.
He's 20 or so assassins line themselves
up at various intervals on this parade
route and planned to kill the archduke
as soon as they can.
The archduke car is either going too
fast or there are too many other serves
in the crowd nearby.
The first few assassins,
so the first few assassins don't try to
make a run at him.
Eventually he passes.
One guy who runs out from the crowd with
a bomb,
really more of a hand grenade would be a
good way to describe it today,
and he flings this hand grenade at the
archduke open car in a very athletic
maneuver.
The archduke sees it ducks behind the
door of the car,
the hand grenade thing bounces off the
car,
hits the concrete on the street,
and the fuse doesn't detonate until the
next car in the motorcade has passed
over it.
It explodes.
Some 20 people are badly hurt in a blood
on the street.
The whole thing.
Chaos.
The crowd scatters.
I mean obviously you know,
the parade is over.
The would be assassins shoves a cyanide
pill into his mouth and runs down into
the side of the street and jumps in the
river,
but the cyanide pill is defective and
only makes them vomit and the river is
only about six inches deep.
So they capture him very quickly and run
him off to be interrogated.
And basically the whole day is now
scotched.
All the other assassins along the parade
route have had their chance,
spoiled and everybody breaks up and goes
their separate ways.
The crowd dissipates and the motorcade,
you know,
takes off in a couple of different
directions.
The injured or taken to hospitals in the
archduke goes to the local magistrates
residents to lodge a complaint.
So you think,
okay,
there's a bullet dodge literally,
so after complaining to the local
authority is the archduke decides
instead of just leaving town,
I mean,
you know,
he almost got killed,
but instead of leaving town in a very
heroic sort of,
um,
movie decides no,
he needs to visit the people injured in
the bombing,
just going to go to the hospital and he
gets back into the open car with his
wife and they speed off toward the
hospital to talk to the wounded and
comfort the wounded.
The local authorities are worried,
as you might imagine.
So they give him some extra security,
including one guy who was,
I'm a member of a local aristocracy
account named France Bon Herat.
And her rock takes a position on the
running board right by the archduke side
of the car and they speed off for the
hospital.
Now no one knows where the arch duke is
going now.
None of the people who were would be
assassins or anything.
This is not a published route.
Nobody knows that the archduke is
heading in this direction.
So the car drives toward the hospital.
Meanwhile,
you know Gavrilo Princip has gone to get
a sandwich,
mean his day has been totally destroyed.
He couldn't have been in a good mood.
He must've felt like they'd failed
somewhat and the driver of the archduke
car not really knowing the route very
well,
charged down a street,
realizes he's on the wrong street and
reverses the car,
but this is 1914 and cars are relatively
new and simply reversing a car could
stall the engine,
which is exactly what happens.
He tries to reverse the car,
the engine stalls,
and there it is sitting,
not moving,
and they're trying to get it started
again and out of the restaurant where
he'd gone to get that,
I guess you could say constellation
Sandwich to make them feel a little bit
better about how his bad day went.
Steps Gavrilo Princip who looks up and
sees his target from a little while ago,
five feet away from him,
immobile and slightly below him in an
open car
and he whips out his pistol and shoots
him and his wife.
What are the odds of that happening?
It's considered to be one of the most
wild coincidences in all of human
history and we sometimes forget because
it's such a monumental historical moment
that this is still a terrorist attack
and it was quite upsetting to either
witness or lived through.
Part of what makes these things seemed
so unreal is that we only have grainy
black and white footage of even the
events before that you can go see movies
where you can see the archduke and his
wife getting ready to go into the
motorcade and you get an idea of what
they looked like and it's all kind of
moving a little too fast.
The way those old fashioned movies were
and everything and it just doesn't look
real.
But you can go and you can see pictures
because they have saved the tunic that
the archduke was wearing that day and
you can see in living color that this
was a bright light blue tunic and the
feathers on the helmet he was wearing
were bright green.
I mean,
it must've been the most colorful site
imaginable,
but after princip fired the most
colorful site imaginable became a lot
more gory.
Because there's a tear in the tunic
where the bullet exited the archduke
neck and the tunic is covered and what
is unmistakably.
Even 100 years later,
blood and blood has always been one of
those things where when you see it in
living color,
there's nothing like it.
I tend to believe human beings are
programmed to react to that specific
color,
you know,
always,
and the difference between seeing blood
in black and white and blood and color
is there's nothing quite like that.
The person who was closest
to the whole thing was count von
[inaudible],
who was on the running board,
not doing that great of a job apparently
at security,
and he says,
as soon as the shots were fired,
they reversed the car
and he later testified this quote,
as the car quickly reversed,
a thin stream of blood spurted from his
highness,
his mouth onto my right cheek.
As I was pulling out my handkerchief to
wipe the blood away from his mouth.
The dutchess cried out to him.
For God's sake.
What has happened to you at that?
She slid off the seat and lay on the
floor of the car with her face between
his knees.
I had no idea that she too was hit and
thought that she had simply fainted with
fright.
Then I heard his imperial highness say,
Sophie,
don't die.
Stay alive for the children.
At that I seized the archduke by the
collar of his uniform to stop his head
drooping forward and asked him if he was
in great pain.
He answered me quite distinctly.
It is nothing.
His face began to twist somewhat,
but he went on repeating six or seven
times evermore faintly as he gradually
lost consciousness.
It's nothing.
Then came a brief pause followed by a
convulsive rattling his throat caused by
the loss of blood.
This ceased on arrival at the governor's
residence.
That to unconscious bodies were carried
into the building where their death was
soon established.
End Quote,
and as a way to sort of prove that the
old adage that one man's terrorist is
another man's freedom fighter is true.
The spot where princip was standing when
he fired those fatal shots are
immortalized now in the city of
Sarajevo.
With a plaque and the actual footsteps,
you know,
in metal on the ground where the spot
was to Serbs,
this guy was a hero and to his
compatriots who all realized that they
were like Desperados at the time.
They all realized that they would be
immortalized too,
and the actual circumstances by the way,
where this plot was hatched are worthy
of a spy novel and it's hard to believe
it hasn't been romanticized to some
degree.
But nevertheless,
if you ever do the definitive big screen
dramatization of World War One,
the whole story.
I think you want to start your movie off
with that scene inside that Belgrade
cafe obscure place Kinda run down lit
only by candle light with a group of 19
and 20 year old guys at a table.
I always have to remind myself how young
these people are not old enough to
legally drink alcohol in the United
States is how old these people are.
And then we're told by people who were
there that what happened is one of their
number comes in the door,
sits down at the table with them and has
a package with him.
And he opens up the package and inside
is only one thing,
a newspaper clipping.
No,
no,
not signed it by anybody.
No directions,
just a newspaper clipping.
And the clipping announces
the imminent visit of the archduke Franz
Ferdinand to Siri,
Ava,
one of the people who was at that table
and lived to grow older and write about
his experiences after he'd had time to
go from terrorists to Patriot,
a guy named Jeff Church.
And if I mispronounced that by the way,
let's just get used to that.
This is going to be perhaps the most
linguistically and essentially
challenging show I've ever done.
And I'm sure to mangle many beautiful
languages,
uh,
first and foremost French.
So my apologies to all of you in
advance.
I'm sorry I have limitations and you're
going to hear them all.
I'm bored.
Shoved Jeff Church wrote years later
this about that moment in history that
will turn out to be so very important in
a way that you can't imagine anyone at
the table then would have known they
didn't know they were pulling the
trigger again and that Russian roulette
game.
And they certainly didn't know that if
they were,
that was the time there was going to be
a bullet in the chamber.
So you have to troll,
you know,
after the fact,
quote,
a tiny clipping from a newspaper mailed
without comment from a secret band of
terrorists in Zagreb,
a capital of Croatia,
to their comrades in Belgrade was the
torch which set the world of fire with
the war in 1914,
that bit of paper wrecked old proud
empires.
It gave birth to new free nations.
I was one of the members of the
terrorist band in Belgrade,
which received it.
And in those days I and my companions
were regarded as desperate criminals.
A price was on our heads.
Today,
my little band is seen in a different
light as pioneer patriots.
It is recognized that our secret plans
hatched in an obscure cafe and the
capital of old Serbia have led to the
independence of the new Yugoslavia,
the United Nation set free from Austrian
domination.
And to quote now,
ever since that time,
people have been wondering how connected
that group was to outside entities.
No,
they just a bunch of small little self
organized terror groups put together by
a bunch of young kids,
or are they working for a larger entity
today?
We would ask whether or not they were an
example of state sponsored terrorism.
Was there a power behind this group
arrival power,
I mean in to understand how big of a
deal this could be in a Europe that was
already kind of unsteady and stressed in
terms of stability.
Imagine the United States president or a
president or two from now.
We don't want to be controversial down
the road is assassinated and we have all
the shock and anger and desire for
retribution that comes with that and
then very shortly after an assassin is
captured,
we figure out that that assassin is
working with the intelligence service
for our most antagonistic enemy.
I mean,
think for a second how America would
have reacted if Lee Harvey Oswald had
been a hit man for Moscow and that came
to light,
which by the way is not that outrageous
thing to consider.
When you look at Oswald's ties to the
Soviet Union and Cuba,
think about how the American people
would have reacted regardless of what
the facts were if they thought that was
the case,
and it's interesting to note that that's
only a year after the Cuban missile
crisis,
a year after world war three is
potentially dodged.
What do you think the leaders of the
United States after Kennedy is
assassinated,
are worried about in terms of worst case
scenarios?
Do you think it might have occurred to
them men who by the early 19 sixties had
grown up during and in the immediate
years after the first World War,
do you think they might have been seeing
in their mind's eye history,
repeating itself?
A world leader killed by a gunman in an
open car with his wife sitting next to
him in public by a young person may be
working for a foreign government and
then having the world spiral out of
control despite what the major players
may have wanted.
Do you think the people around Kennedy
might have worried a little about how
that might have turned out?
Because those guys in that cafe very
well may have been working for the
Serbian intelligence service.
There's been a lot written about this.
No one knows for sure.
They certainly have ties to groups that
the United States today,
if we were ranking groups from 1914,
would probably call terrorist groups
like young Bosnia and another one called
the black hand,
and these groups had ties sometimes to
the Serbian intelligence service,
so you can believe the historian where
the investigator,
you want to believe it's a hot button
issue.
Nonetheless,
it isn't so important.
What really happened,
just like it isn't so important whether
or not Oswald was working for the Soviet
Union.
What's important is what did the people
on the ground effected by this think was
happening.
The US public thought Oswald was a
hitman from Moscow.
What happens then?
The Austrians thought the killing of
their heir to the throne was an active
state sponsored terrorism,
and if it wasn't,
they were going to make the case that it
was anyway.
There's really no doubt that the
Austrian Hungarian Empire wanted to deal
with this Serbian problem that had been
bedeviling it for some time,
once and for all,
and to be honest,
it's hard to blame them.
I mean the Serbians and the Slavs will
counter with the idea that the
Austro-hungarian had not possess this
territory for very long.
Bosnia Herzegovina and places like Siri,
Ava had not been Austro-hungarian for a
long time.
Nevertheless,
you try to think of what nation state on
the planet could put
up with the nation over their border
fomenting revolution in their country
and eventually killing their public
figures.
I mean,
imagine if you're an American.
This happening in the United States.
Imagine say Mexico creating instability
and unrest and fomenting subversion and
revolution in places like southern Texas
and southern New Mexico and southern
Arizona and southern California,
and then eventually these
revolutionaries that have been Egged on
by the Mexican intelligence service kill
a major US public figure.
How long do you think United States will
put up with something like that?
The reason it becomes so important
though is because of all the many
controversies in the story.
One of the most enduring and important
is who's fault.
Everything that's about to happen is you
know,
if this is a civil lawsuit,
trying to figure out who's responsible
for damages is a key part of this story
and the Austrian Hungarian Empire is in
a position to decide to go or not to go
to war.
That seems to put them in the driver's
seat.
Responsibility Wise,
there are Austrians though,
living at the time who basically say,
what choice did they have?
Take this Austrian writing after the war
as a perfect example.
He talks about archduke.
Franz Ferdinand is one of the best
friends the slavs ever had,
and in effect,
Ferdinand actually was counseling his
government to treat the Serbian problem
more lightly because he was worried
about it's sparking a general war.
When he was killed,
it was seen as an extra perfidious act
because the Slavic folks had killed a
person who had been,
you know,
one of their better friends in the
Austrian government.
The Austrian that I was telling you
about a second ago after the first World
War wrote this quote,
when the news of the murder of archduke
Franz Ferdinand arrived in Munich.
I happened to be sitting at home and
heard of it only vaguely.
I was at first seized with worry that
the bullets may have been shot from the
pistols of German students who have
indignation at the heirs apparent
continuous work of Slava.
Ization wanted to free the German people
from this internal enemy.
What the consequence of this would have
been,
was easy to imagine a new wave of
persecution which now would have been
justified and explained in the eyes of
the whole world.
But when soon afterward I heard the name
of the supposed that assassins and
moreover read that they had been
identified as Serbs.
A light shutter began to run through me
at this vengeance of inscrutable
destiny.
The greatest friend of the slobs had
fallen beneath the bullets of Slavic
fanatics.
Anyone he says,
with constant occasion in the last years
to observe the relation of Austria to
Serbia,
could not for a be in doubt that the
stone had been set rolling whose course
could no longer be arrested.
Those who today he writes,
shower the Viennese government with
reproaches on the form and content of
this ultimatum.
It issued do it an injustice.
No other power in the world could have
acted differently in the same situation
and the same position at her south
eastern border,
Austria possessed in an Oxford and
mortal enemy who had shorter and shorter
intervals,
kept challenging the monarchy and would
never have left off until the moment
favorable for the shattering of the
empire had arrived and quote.
I actually agree with that and it makes
me uncomfortable because the Austrian
writing that statement after the first
world war is the man most responsible
for beginning the second adult Hitler.
The one line that I think Hitler Eridean
though was his line that this stone had
been set rolling,
that nothing could arrest because
something could have arrested it because
something had been arresting it.
There's a reason that the ostrow
Hungarians had an attack.
The Serbs are ready,
and the reason was that the Serbs had a
very powerful friend,
the Russians who considered themselves
the traditional protectors of the Slavs
and the Serbs were not alone.
Most of the powers of Europe had at
least one and usually more powerful
friends and allies.
This was the era in European history and
it's often used as an example of one of
the main reasons this whole story
unfolds the way it does.
This is the era of a very complex web of
alliances that bind European countries
to each other.
It's perhaps the most enduring work of
Otto von Bismarck can.
We mentioned earlier the 19th century
German diplomat,
bismarck played a very large role in the
foundation of modern Germany,
but he also played a huge role in
creating a system of alliances that both
expanded,
you know,
Germany's possibilities while at the
same time preserving a general peace in
Europe.
There were wars between Napoleon and the
first world war.
There's no doubt about that and some of
them were directly the fault of Bismark,
but there wasn't a general European
conflict involving all the major powers
and let's not forget that this is an era
that we would today call a multipolar
world,
which is hard for us to understand in an
era of one or two super powers.
Europe during this time period had at
least five first rate power states,
Britain,
France,
Germany,
Russia,
and the Austrian Hungarian Empire.
Many people throw in Turkey and Italy to
which would make seven.
These states all,
we're bound to each other with complex
alliance systems and complex is the way
bismarck wanted it.
Bismarck had set it up so that basically
no matter what happened,
he was in the driver's
and this worked unbelievably well,
especially for German interests,
but for European interests as well as a
whole for a long time.
But by the time 1914 rolls around this
genius who create this system that's so
complex,
only he knew how to run it.
I've taken whole courses on Biz markie
and diplomacy from professors who spent
their whole life studying it and they
don't know why he did some of the things
he did while he was running it.
It was fantastic.
By the time 1914 rolls around,
he hasn't been running it for some time.
He'd been fired by the leader of Germany
and now this complex machine that the
genius of Bismarck had created and run
was being run by people who couldn't,
you know,
carry his jockstrap is what we used to
say.
It was inevitable that something like
that would break down the reason that
the Austra Hungarians didn't just march
into Serbia,
you know,
the minute they found out that the Serbs
were responsible for killing their heir
to the throne,
is that they knew that would mean war
with Russia and that is something that
the ostrow Hungarians were not prepared
for.
At least not without checking with their
main friend on the world stage and
finding out,
you know,
what they would do in that situation.
Their main friend on the world stage was
the German empire.
Now the German empires attitude is very
interesting.
The first thing I have to keep reminding
myself about the German Empire during
this era is that it's relatively young.
It's a new country almost.
It was only founded in 18,
71.
I was like 40 years before this era and
it wasn't just a new country.
The minute it was proclaimed and that's
how it happened.
You didn't proclaiming England,
you didn't proclaim France,
but Germany is a modern nation.
There was like a day where people signed
papers and okay,
the next day as of tomorrow,
Germany exists and the minute it
existed,
it was the most powerful land power in
Europe with a larger population than
France.
Traditionally the greatest land power in
Europe up till this time period and a
larger faster birth rate and more
industry,
and how destabilizing would it be in our
world today if a couple of different
nations of moderate power signed a piece
of paper tomorrow that united them into
one country and that one now combined
country was the most powerful country in
the world.
Even if it was just the most powerful
land power or the most powerful see
power,
you can see how a bunch of nations that
really didn't deserve a lot of the perks
that the super great nations claim for
themselves might all of a sudden do that
once they turn themselves into a super
nation in 18,
71 with the creation of Germany,
the Kaiser,
right?
You have an instant great power on the
world stage.
It was Prussia on steroids with a
population like eight times as much and
the rest of Germany with the militarized
on the Prussian model with the Prussian
King.
That's a very destabilizing thing and
when that country begins to demand some
of the perks that the other great powers
have,
you know,
have their own France,
Great Britain,
they've got all these colonies,
all these other things,
little Holland to them looks like
they've got places all over the world.
What's going on?
Sort of a factor of just having been
there for awhile.
If you were around during the age of
exploration and you had a bunch of ships
out there,
you were getting colonies.
Germany didn't come around until most of
the good stuff was taken.
Was a cause of instability.
Germany worried about being encircled.
That powers all around them that didn't
wish them well.
His Neil Ferguson,
I'm in.
The thing that I really thought was was
quite wonderful because here in the
west,
those of us who fought the German empire
famously said that they had this sort of
paranoia about being encircled.
They were always worried about being
encircled.
We'll look at them on a map.
They're born in circle there in central
Europe.
They've got enemy is all around them.
Neil Ferguson said they weren't paranoid
about being historical.
They were being encircled and they were
worried about an upcoming war and up
until Otto von Bismarck goes away,
he had neutralized Russia.
That was one of the main things in his
diplomatic alliance system.
Keep the Russians happy.
He said it in a five superpower world.
Make sure your country's one of three.
Right?
So it's always three against two and
Russia was always to be kept on your
good side when he was sacked and
basically the foreign policy begins to
be heavily influenced by the German
Kaiser.
The Emperor Kaiser Means Caesar,
by the way.
So imagine you know,
calling your Emperor Caesar in 1914.
In any case,
the Kaiser was a strange guy.
He sacks bismarck because bismarck's
kind of talking down to him and is kind
of running the show and he's an old guy
by then in these much revered and you
know,
how do you grow into your own man?
Would that guy hanging over your
shoulder?
So he fires him and he allows that
machine to make vital mistakes bismarck
never would have made with that
diplomatic machine.
Vital mistake,
number one,
he lost the Russians.
He intentionally drove them away
basically
right into the hands of the French,
the historic German enemy,
the one that they had beaten in the
Franco Prussian war in 18,
78 slash 71.
That allowed them to proclaim the German
empire,
which they did in the French palace of
Versailles,
which is sort of a rub your nose in it
kind of thing.
The Germans and the French assumed
they'd fight each other again someday.
Now the French were allied with the
Russians and now the German fears of
encirclement had become a reality.
The Germans had been trying to plan for
what they're going to do with a war,
you know,
against an enemy to their west and
another enemy to their east at the same
time.
Right.
How do you do that?
And now the situation in Australia boils
over and the Austrian say to the
Germans,
listen,
if we get into a war with Serbia,
Russia is going to attack us.
If Russia attacks us,
where do you stand?
And the,
this is controversial,
but traditionally the Kaiser is supposed
to have told the Austrians to go for it.
Get Serbia had done now.
And some historians.
Again,
this is all very controversial.
Everybody has a different opinion.
Um,
but basically the idea seems to be that
the Kaiser believed that if it was done
quickly enough,
the Serbians could be crushed before the
situation spiraled out of control in
Europe because even as moderately
intelligent,
we'll put,
we'll give them some credit that the
Kaiser was,
he knew that Europe was a powder keg and
the key thing that had to be avoided was
this process almost a machine,
the cranking up of a doomsday device
that everybody who'd actually been
present when the thinkers who dealt with
the Doomsday Device explained what the
doomsday device did,
understood that once the trigger on this
thing was polled,
it was going to be really hard to turn
it off.
So if the Austrians could conquer the
Serbians before the Russians,
you know,
flip the doomsday device switch,
they would all be okay.
Again,
a lot of controversy on this because
this is again another one of those
places where the war guilt question
hinges.
Did Germany tell Austria to go crush
Serbia?
And who cares if the Russians attack
everybody?
But of course the problem wasn't that it
would just involve the Russians
attacking everybody.
Because of that complex web of alliances
we talked about earlier,
other countries,
we're going to get dragged into the
conflict.
This was something that was well
understood by the intelligent heads of
Europe.
Take for example,
the British prime minister.
During this time period,
Herbert Asquith Asquith wrote a letter,
a private lender that's coming down to
the history books right after Serbia
receives the ultimatum from Austria
that's so important and ask with writes,
quote,
Austria has sent a bullying and
humiliating ultimatum to Serbia who
cannot possibly comply with it and then
demanded an answer within 48 hours
failing,
which she will march.
This means almost inevitably that Russia
will come to the scene and defensive
Serbia and in defiance of Austria,
and if so,
it's difficult for Germany and France to
refrain from lending a hand to one side
or the other so that we are in
measurable or imaginable distance of a
real armageddon.
Happily,
there seems to be no reason why we
should be anything more than spectators
and quote.
Well,
that turned out obviously to be wishful
thinking on the British prime ministers
part,
but historians like Neil Ferguson who
write revisionist works like the pity of
war,
have suggested that if the British had
stayed out,
we'd have a better world today for all
sorts of reasons.
I mean,
he knocks off many of the biggest events
of the 20th century.
The most horrible saying this never
happens.
That never happens.
If Britain stays out of the war,
Britain can stay out of the work as they
don't have a hard alliance with anyone.
They're not caught up in that web of
alliances will not too much.
They have an understanding with France
and understanding with enough wiggle
room so that there was a lot of talk in
Britain about do we or don't we get
involved in this whole thing?
This whole thing was something that
hadn't happened in a hundred years in
Europe,
a general European war.
It hadn't happened since Napoleon,
since Waterloo,
and that war was so terrible.
Not just that we're the entire
Napoleonic wars and the wars of the
French revolution.
That era from like 1789 to 1815,
so awful in terms of military
destruction that a lesson had been
talked to the,
you know,
crown heads of Europe and the lesson
was,
was not as much of a game anymore.
It's no longer,
you know,
these small private armies that we move
around our European Chessboard and Oh,
I lost to you so you can have this
province and then on next time I'll beat
you and I'll take that province back.
You know,
nobody was trying to topple over their
regimes.
It was,
if anything,
gentlemanly warfare,
if there's ever been such a thing,
it's been called in the history books,
limited warfare or restricted warfare.
There was an Italian historian named
Ferraro 1933 who talked about how,
you know,
that era of warfare was the kind of
warfare where you know,
the leaders of countries can actually
have fun.
Going to war.
War was something you just sort of did,
like pheasant hunting,
at least in the minds of some of these
guys I'm Ferrara writes,
quote,
restricted warfare was one of the
loftiest achievements of the 18th
century.
It belongs to a class of hothouse
plants,
which can only thrive in an aristocratic
and qualitative civilization.
We are no longer capable of it.
It's one of the things we have lost as a
result of the French revolution and the
French Revolution was when warfare,
God,
at least in the minds of the Europeans,
have this era,
you know,
really serious,
you want a war,
then we're going to go to war.
The crown heads of Europe attack France
after France went all revolutionary,
and you have to understand how much of a
shock that was.
Historian Gwynne Dyer has a great way of
describing it.
He says,
to understand the shock of the crown
heads of Europe when the most royal of
European countries,
the French were overthrown by leftist
revolutionaries.
He says,
you have to imagine if Maoists toppled
the US government today.
Maoist of course,
being a very hardcore communist group.
Imagine them toppling today's US
government and beginning to govern.
He goes,
that's how the crown heads of Europe
felt about the French revolution and how
destabilizing it was seen.
So inevitably,
the royalty of Europe,
which is almost all of Europe,
clashes with this new republic in France
and coalesces into an alliance and
everybody attacks France and they do so
with their private mercenary armies and
they run into the entire French
population,
a people in arms because France started
by losing.
You have to imagine a state where the
entire underpinnings of the state have
been broken down,
including especially the army.
And then all I mean pressure rush
Australia and Great Britain.
All these powers in Europe attack France
at the same time and you're stuck with.
I mean like a bit of your army leftover.
The artillery stayed with the people.
So the old French artillery was good,
but you've got this mishmash of an army
with officers.
You don't have any authority.
It's crazy.
And France is about to be defeated.
And then as only you know,
totalitarian regimes can do,
they basically tell the people of France
that the war is now everything.
Our entire focus,
the entire society exists only to win
this war.
The decree of the French national
convention in Seventeen,
93 said,
quote from this moment until that in
which our enemies shall have been driven
from the territory of the republic.
All Frenchmen are permanently
requisition for service in the army's.
The young men shall fight.
The married men shall forge weapons and
transport supplies.
The women will make tents and clothes
and serve in the hospitals.
The public buildings shall be turned
into barracks,
the public squares into munition
factories.
All firearms have suitable caliber,
shall be turned over to the troops.
The interior will be policed with
shotguns and cold steel.
All saddled horses shall be seized for
the cavalry.
All draft horses not employed in
cultivation will draw the artillery and
supply wagons and quote.
In other words,
the entire society was mobilized for the
war effort.
This was not something that the other
countries did.
In fact,
most of the royal,
you know,
leaders of Europe could think of nothing
more scary than arming and training your
population.
Oftentimes,
they used their professional militaries
to put down rebellions by their
population.
The last thing they wanted to do was
give them guns and train them how to use
it,
right.
Train them how to be better.
Street fighters wasn't going to happen,
but the French had a different kind of
society,
one that was supposed to be run by the
very,
you know,
low born people.
Everybody was in this together and you
combine the willingness to throw human
life,
you know,
out there on the battlefield in almost
endless numbers.
You didn't have to pay these people
either.
You could just say,
I'm sorry you're out of work right now.
You're going to the front and the,
uh,
steal some chickens from some farmer on
the way this was crazy and all of a
sudden the French were able to expend
lives on a scale that was unprecedented.
And to create armies that were enormous.
I mean,
look at Alexander the Great,
probably the greatest conqueror in all
world history.
Alexander conquers a very large chunk of
the known world and a decent sized chunk
of the unknown world at the time with an
army that numbered anywhere from 40 to
90,000
men.
Okay.
And he was obviously a genius in the way
he did it,
but imagine if Alexander could have used
a historical xerox machine to duplicate
that world conquering army so that now
he's got 2:40
to $90,000,
man armies roughly comparable to each
other.
Now imagine he does it again and then
duplicate it again.
And then again,
and then again,
you do that enough times to where you
got one point two,
one point three,
one point 5 million men,
maybe eventually closer to 3 million
men.
And now you've given Alexander the Great
Twentieth Century Army,
a 20th century.
Army is many,
many armies from the past.
The French revolution is when that
really starts.
When you start putting so many troops
into the field that it doesn't matter
that there are practically incompetent,
that their lives are wasted,
that they're turned into cannon fodder
as Napoleon who will inherit this.
You know,
people's army that will conscript every
man they want to conscript as long as
they need them.
We'll say troops are born to be killed.
And as Napoleon famously said to the
Austrian diplomat,
count,
medtronic,
you cannot stop me.
I spend 30,000
lives a month,
if any of the major powers except maybe
Russia in Europe at this time,
last 30,000
men in a month,
it would be considered quite a blow.
Napoleon lost 30,000
men a month as a matter of course,
because he had a new kind of army.
He had a people in arms and in order to
beat him,
the other countries of Europe had to do
the same thing as the German field.
Marshal,
blue shirt told the PRUSSIAN government
after the Russians had been defeated by
Napoleon,
give me a national army,
gave me what he has and when he got it,
you know which the Russian aristocracy
didn't want to do for the same reason
that the European leaders everywhere
didn't want to do it.
They didn't want to put the people in
arms,
but when they did,
they were able to triple the size of
blue shirts army and he took that army
and fought Napoleon with it.
The creation of a nation in arms was the
first step in creating the modern war
machine because now all of a sudden life
was cheap.
Not only was life cheap,
but the modern nation state was now deep
enough to be able to truly take a punch,
and this is what sets the modern
militaries off in the modern states,
off from the ones in ancient times.
In ancient times,
very few states could take a punch,
you know,
to use a boxing term.
Many of them could dish it out.
When you take a state like the acumen
had Persians,
you know the ones who fought the
spartans at thermopylae and all that.
The Persians Kodesh out really good
blows,
but they couldn't take very many good
blows.
Most nations in the past couldn't.
That's why if you look at a book,
you know the greatest battles in
history.
If it's beyond,
you know about 150 ago sometimes the
great battle is the only battle the wars
are won or lost on one big battle
because the nation states couldn't take
too many punches.
They couldn't reraise armies.
The state just couldn't support it.
Once France turns the entire nation into
the war,
effort,
nations can take punches better.
And in the past,
I mean the goals and the Chinese could
take some punches.
The Roman Empire could take punches.
That's what set those nation states in
the past,
apart from most of their enemies,
right?
They,
they had more staying power.
They had modern staying power.
The French Revolution teaches all these
states to have modern staying power.
The only problem with modern staying
power is that the killing can go on
longer.
In boxing,
they always feel like an early knockout
is more merciful than a long match.
Because in a long match you take a lot
more punishment.
Well,
in a funny way,
if everything can be decided at one big
horrific battle,
you know,
at the start of a war that has a lot
less costly over time than a four or a
five year long conflict where both sides
grind each other.
Down to the NUB.
The Napoleonic wars created multiple
states in Europe capable of fighting
until they were ground down to the NUB,
which meant a lot more damage and
destruction.
Before these wars came to a halt.
The modern nation state provided the
support that the militaries that
involved entire peoples in arms needed
to keep the struggle going,
you know,
for long periods of time,
one half of the equation necessary to
create the modern war machines.
As military historian Gwynne dyer rights
right after he talks about the human
costs of these,
you know,
Long Napoleonic wars.
He says,
quote,
almost as important is the fact that
European society did not break down
under the strain.
There was hardship,
but no starvation and the warring powers
were able to keep at it and keep their
people at it year after year with no end
in sight.
The European states had developed the
wealth,
the organizational techniques and the
methods of motivation needed to fight
mass wars with a degree of popular
participation that no other civilized
society had ever even approached.
All that was lacking.
He writes to transform mass warfare into
total war was the technology,
but the industrial revolution was
already almost a generation old and 18,
14 and soon it would begin to fill the
last remaining gap and to quote what was
missing to make this new deadly machine
that the Napoleonic wars and the French
revolution created was the technology to
increase the deadliness by exponential
amounts and that was already something
that was happening.
The 18 hundreds are an era in military
history where the killing power of
machines skyrockets and machines have
been an important part of battlefields
since before.
There were cities in human societies to
field mass armies at all.
Think of the bow and Arrow,
that's a neolithic weapon.
That's a stone age machine that made man
a more efficient killer both in hunting
but on the battlefield as well.
By the time the 18 hundreds roll around
the machines,
killing power skyrockets,
but because there is no major war
involving all the great powers between
Napoleon and the first world war,
the actual demonstration of how this
stuff can be used is lacking and the
military powers of the world.
Try to examine the conflicts that do
happen to see if they can learn any
lessons about what the next war is
likely to be like.
There were European observers,
for example,
at the American civil war,
to try to see,
you know,
what you could learn from that.
The Crimean war breaks out in the 18
fifties between Russia and Britain and
France.
There's a war obviously between the
United States and Spain that involve
Cuba and the Philippines in,
uh,
right around the turn of the century
going into the 19 hundreds,
probably most importantly,
there's a war between Japan and Russia
in 1905 where some of the use of these,
you know,
new weapons that when fused together
create the modern war machine where some
of that was observable.
The one thing that seems to be the key
element as far as European planners can
figure it out though,
is something that Harkens back to a
phrase from a confederate general in the
US civil war who said that the key to
warfare was to get their firstest with
the mostest.
And the idea now of these mass armies
that you're a peg created was that you
needed to be able to raise them and get
them to the battlefield before the other
side beat you to it.
The timetable for mobilization becomes a
force that none of the major European
powers seem to be anything but a slave
to once the assassin's bullet in
Sarajevo cuts down the Austrian
archduke.
When the archduke is killed by
principal,
he does the equivalent of pulling a pan
on a hand grenade.
Imagine trying to hold negotiations to
ward off an explosion with a guy who's
already pulled the pin on the grenade,
right?
You have a limited amount of time to
convince them of anything.
Winston Churchill,
during his life had famously said that
jaw jaw was better than war.
War,
meaning negotiation is always better
than war,
but at the person's already pulled the
pin on the hand grenade.
You have a very short window of
opportunity to avoid the inevitable.
And that's where Europe finds itself.
After the archduke is murdered.
Everybody's worried about the same thing
too.
There's an old phrase,
the peace movement used to use in the
late 19 sixties,
early 19 seventies where they would say,
what if they gave a war and nobody came?
Well,
the military planners in Europe at this
time period or worried about something a
little bit different.
What if war breaks out and on the days
that hostilities commence,
only one side's got their army there.
I mean,
if it takes you 30 days to get your
reservists in uniform to the mustering
point,
into the battlefield before they're
ready to fight,
how big of a deal is it if it only takes
your opponent 15 days to do the same
thing?
This puts a huge crunch,
you know,
timewise on everybody in this story and
constrains the ability to negotiate your
way out of this situation.
Everybody feels like,
okay,
the first person that flips the
mobilization switch,
we all go because nobody wants to fall
behind.
The Germans have constrained themselves
even more timewise by the way,
that they have found a solution to their
terrible dilemma of how do you fight a
two front war?
You know,
once you violate bismark's dictum of,
you know,
keep the Russians on your side and then
the Russians and the French ally with
each other and war breaks out.
You're going to be fighting the French
and the West and the Russians and the
east at the same time
and in the intervening decades,
the fantastic German general staff had
figured out a way to not just survive
that situation but to win that war.
But it involved exquisite timing which
further constrained the amount of
negotiation room you had before the
grenade went off.
The timing involved taking advantage of
the fact that everyone thought the
Russians were going to take forever to
mobilize.
The Russians were seen as a giant,
somewhat clumsy colossus,
less organized than the Germans and the
French and people like that.
And so by the time the Russians could
get their act together and get their
monstrous armies in the field ready to
fight,
Germany already would have defeated
France.
Their entire plan for action involved
throwing almost all their weight against
the French immediately and then turning
after French forces were defeated and
throwing those forces against the now
ready to fight Russians,
but this did two things,
so the Germans one,
it meant the Russians could have no
advanced time mobilizing.
You couldn't let them mobilize for three
or four days while you waited to
negotiate,
putting the pin back in the grenade.
You didn't have that kind of time.
You were going to screw up your entire
plan for winning the war.
If you did that.
The other thing that it meant is that if
you went to war with Russia,
you had to attack France.
You had to assume that the French would
come in at some time and the only thing
you had a plan to deal with was to
attack the French first.
So if you go into war with Russia,
you get to attack France as part of the
bargain,
but it was even more of a concern than
that.
It involved attacking countries besides
France.
Countries had no
disagreement with it.
All neutral countries.
That just happened to be in the way the
Germans had come up with a plan to deal
with their encirclement problem,
but it involved launching essentially a
world war in their own defense.
The other thing that prince did was
provide an opportunity for a lot of
these leaders who thought war was coming
anyway to decide that now was better
than later,
and this is another interesting side of
the conflict,
but if you're part of these many
military staffs that are absolutely sure
wars coming and you know you can read
accounts from every major military,
the time period we're numbers of their
military planners thought war was
inevitable.
The question is,
if it's going to be inevitable,
is it better to fight it now than
lighter?
The Germans were under the impression
that the Russians were on their way to
superpower status,
which if you look at what happened in
the 20th century,
is exactly how it turned out.
The Germans felt that by 1917,
that was going to be a reality that
Russians were completing major military
reforms,
major transportation reforms.
They were taking advantage of huge
French bank loans to do this stuff.
The Germans figured if more comes in
three years,
we're going to be in a much worse
situation than we are now,
so if it's here,
we might as well do it.
Now.
We have an advantage now.
We won't have later.
The French felt similarly about the
Germans.
The Germans felt about the Russians.
They were looking at the German birth
rate and just going,
we're going to be swamped.
They were looking at the growth in
industry.
I mean the Germans were on a tear,
so if war came in five or six or seven
years,
the French are just going to be worse
off.
So they figured the same thing if was
going to come,
let it come now and amidst these
interesting conflicts of interest in
worries about timing and all this stuff,
the world sees where it's heading and
tries to pull back from the brink,
but instead of having,
you know,
the greatest statesman Europe can
produce during this time period.
Some of these countries are saddled with
people who are like millstones around
the neck of peace.
People like Kaiser Wilhelm,
the second the emperor of Germany and
leadership is such an interesting side
of this conflict because I firmly
believe,
had you had a guy of Otto von Bismarck
caliber in a position of authority in
Germany when the first world war is on
the verge of happening,
that they could put the pin back in the
grenade.
You know,
the governor,
Lowe Prinsep,
metaphorically pulled in Sarajevo.
I think it could have been done and all
it would have required would have been
some real diplomatic quality.
Brilliance
would have been great,
but I don't even think you needed that.
Just some.
Some high quality workmanship which the
Germans had produced time and again,
the problem was in this time period,
they are stuck with a ruler who could
not have gotten the job if marriage had
been one of the requirements,
you know,
of having it handed to you.
Kaiser Wilhelm.
The second was not a great leader.
He represents the,
you know,
most wonderful example.
You can easily think of of what a roll
of the dice hereditary monarchy is and
how sometimes you get a great role and
you end up with a gifted ruler and then
it almost seems wonderful that they've
got so much power in their hands,
right,
because if someone really knows what to
do with it and does good things with it,
you kind of say to yourself,
I'm glad they had the power to do those
good things,
but that's a bit of a roll of the dice,
isn't it?
As often as you get one of those people,
you get somebody who's evil or cruel or
insane.
Some people throughout history have
rolled very badly on the dice far too
many times,
but it creates good hardcore history
work,
you know,
for us.
I mean the ancient elamites used to roll
whatever the number is that comes up.
That means you get yet another insane
ruler in your dynasties made for fun
reading,
but I wouldn't have wanted to live under
it in Germany,
this current leader,
this current Kaiser Kaiser,
just like czar in Russia where they have
an autocratic king guy to both of those
stem from the word Caesar,
which right there in the 20th century.
Sounds anachronistic,
doesn't it?
And that's part of this old world that
had existed for forever mean King.
An emperor doesn't sound anachronistic
at anytime in history before 1914.
Going back to like Mesopotamia does,
it just sounds weird.
In the 20th century,
shows you how old this world is.
That is marching into the 20th century.
Three of the major powers in this
conflict are ruled by emperors,
kings or czars.
Now they don't have total power.
Well,
the are almost does really a.
The Kaiser's had his chipped away over a
couple generations.
He has to share some power with a German
legislature which has political parties
and they handle budgets and taxation,
but the Kaiser's still has a ton of
power over war and foreign policy and
political appointments and all that,
and he's just this below average guy.
The funny part about the Kaiser is that
the best thing that ever happened to his
reputation was out off Hitler because
when you look at the propaganda and you
read the stuff written about the kaiser
before Hitler comes along and the Kaiser
is treated as this evil character,
malevolent,
you know,
this militaristic want to take over the
world blood falling off of the bay and
at uc in the political cartoons.
And now the attitude that people have
towards him is that he's almost silly or
that he's full of.
You know,
he's just wracked with inferiority
complexes.
He's almost to be pitied.
He's a little mentally doll but,
but there isn't that malevolent evil
sort of thing.
And I think part of the reason why is
when you have Hitler to compare someone
to all of a sudden you see that the
kaiser was just sort of a.
You know,
marginally bad role on the monarchy,
dice for what it's worth.
He was tied into all the other great
monarchies in Europe.
One of the funny twists in the story,
and it actually provides something of
importance because at in Europe at this
time,
the royal families had relatives of
other royal families in Europe,
in their families,
and these families still communicated
with each other,
which provides like a diplomatic back
channel where these rulers can actually
sidestep traditional diplomacy and just
write the family member that rules the
other country.
For example,
Queen Victoria,
who may be the most famous queen in
British history,
maybe the most important ruled forever
presided over Britain during the height
of Britain's power when she's
controlling most of the world and the
Sun proverbially never set on the
British empire.
Queen Victoria's grandchildren are in.
I mean,
well,
Kaiser Wilhelm's,
one of them,
he's Queen Victoria's grandchild.
He's the first cousin of the King of
England.
King George,
right.
Not just that,
but the czar of Russia is married to
another Queen Victoria grandchildren.
So the czar is her son in law.
It's also wilhelm's cousin and when he
gets upset or he wants to talk to the
Russians about something,
he will often sit down and pen.
A quick note to cousin Nikki,
that would be Tsar Nicholas the second.
Now the czar in Russia is another
average to low average role on the
monarchy dice.
It's perhaps telling and some historians
have made it out to be that you end up
with such mediocre leadership in such
powerful countries during this time
period.
It might account for why you know,
these international incidents which
could have led to war previously didn't,
but now are because the leadership
sucks.
I mean in terms of what you could expect
that these people were merit based
leaders.
You know,
you can say what you want about a stolen
or Hitler or even a Mussolini who's been
portrayed again in the west,
like some sort of clown,
but all of those people were formidable
individuals who rose through the ranks
at some level.
I mean,
same thing with American politicians.
I mean a guy like Franklin Roosevelt,
you can say what you want about them,
but that's a formidable human being with
qualities that allowed them to sort of
rise to the top.
That requires a merit based,
something being born into the
hohenzollern family as the oldest son
doesn't require anything.
That's the luck of the draw.
If the job of Kaiser had been merit
based,
Kaiser Wilhelm,
the second wouldn't have gotten anywhere
near it.
And yet he's the guy most responsible
for putting the pin back in the grenade.
If war is going to be avoided here and
you know,
he famously said,
after he sacked bismarck and then sacked
another guy,
he said,
I am my own chancellor,
meaning I'm,
I'm going to run all this myself,
but what do you do when not only are
they sub par in intelligence and
brilliance and all that,
but because they're subpar and if they
can't see that there's sub part and they
don't even take advice.
Well,
I mean,
at one point in the story,
the Kaiser will ask one of his military
leaders to do something that is
ridiculous,
stupid,
lose the war,
stupid.
And the military leader will say it
cannot be done,
and the Kaiser will embarrass him and
say something to the effect of your
uncle who was also a field marshal would
have given me a different answer.
In other words,
he would have done what I wanted him to
do,
even if it was stupid.
The Kaiser,
just to show you how it is too.
So you understand royalty and you
remember in your head you go,
oh yeah,
that's what royalties.
Like this same military leader I just
quoted,
a guy named von Moltke will have to
change the way that the German war games
system works before the first world war
and he will have to put his foot down
and take a career risking move and tell
the kaiser that no longer can they keep
up with the tradition that whatever side
the kaiser is commanding in the German
national war games has to win.
Think about that for a second.
Before Field Marshal von Moltke puts his
foot down,
whatever side that Kaiser is commanding
in these war games,
these national maneuvers of national
security importance,
whatever side of the Kaisers,
commanding wins automatically.
Come on folks.
That's goofy and the Kaiser is a little
goofy.
He's got this one arm that was damaged
during his birth,
which was withered and had no strength.
He couldn't cut his own food,
for example,
which is so embarrassing to a guy who's
already got an inferiority complex.
He goes to England to spend time with
his cousins and they don't really care
for him too much.
The British royal family has kind of
turned off by William and all William
wants is kind of their love and approval
and to be like them.
And what's funny is in this sort of
weird,
I'm almost like tragic playwright kind
of way.
The Kaiser sort of embodies the
inferiority complex that his country has
at this time too.
There are new country on the stage and
they think they're being treated like
trash.
They're mad,
they're chauvinistically.
That's how the British and the French
and those people see them as just these
upstart.
You know,
push their weight around kind of people,
but as many historians have pointed out,
there's no nation in the world that
that's up and coming that doesn't start
to act like it.
And when they do,
the nations that already have it all
don't like it.
I mean,
how do,
how does the United States kind of feel
about China today sort of elbowing its
way into the,
you know,
power structure here.
I mean,
we all understand they deserve it.
You look at their economics,
you look at all the signs,
they,
they're,
they're up and coming,
but nobody necessarily feels like that
person pushing their way in to get their
own space is anything other than a bit
of an upstart during this time period.
The United States plays a similar role.
This sort of elbowing their way into the
world power,
whether the people that are already
there like it or not,
make some room.
Here we come.
That's how the German empire was.
There was a feeling of inferiority and
Kaiser Wilhelm held that sort of
attitude in spades.
But if you read the stuff at the time
she's portrayed as this militarist and
that is the term that is most often for
this German empire that will be blamed
for everything that's happening here.
Okay.
Militarism,
the entire latter part of the 18
hundreds.
People focused on militarism and the
building of these amazingly
technologically deadly armaments and the
race for power.
I mean,
it just seemed like the world was arming
itself to the teeth and it was just
going to explode.
And it was these militarists who were
responsible and people who look at Nazi
Germany and who are,
um,
I know people who are enthralled by the
Wehrmacht and the precision marching and
the uniforms in this whole sort of
militaristic,
fascist attitude that the Nazis
portrayed.
And I always try to tell them that the
Nazis didn't invent this,
that the Nazis were revitalizing regular
German Marshall Attitudes.
That's the niceties.
Militarism.
If you don't like it,
it's Marshall.
If you do like it,
that's what Hitler and his cabal we're
doing is bringing back traditional
Prussian Marshall Practices that goose
stepping,
robotic,
unbelievably efficient,
precision drilling and all that.
Those are qualities that go back to
Frederick the great and it freaked out a
lot.
A lot of the countries in Europe looked
at this and they just,
they look dangerous.
They look mean.
They looked chauvinistically.
They looked like they wanted to take
over your country and then they were
building this giant navy.
Now all of a sudden,
out of nowhere challenging Britain,
because the Kaiser had read that same
book that Theodore Roosevelt read.
Did anybody do more damage than Alfred?
They are may hand when he decides to
write a book on naval history because
the Kaiser,
like Roosevelt,
Reddit,
was enthralled with it,
made all his,
you know,
ab rules,
read it,
and then decided he was going to build
this fleet to compete with Britain so
that they wouldn't take him for granted.
Fascinating character.
A perfect example though of what can
happen with the role of the monarchy
dice.
Now,
of course,
all the governments in Europe that
matter are not all monarchies and
autocratic governments.
There are the famous governments of
France and Britain,
for example,
Francis,
a republic.
Again,
by this time having tried out royalty
again after Napoleon decided that they
liked the republic idea better and there
are republic and Britain might as well
be by this time period.
They still have the king and the royalty
and all that,
but they don't have any power anymore
than they were during this time period.
The way the royal family is now,
maybe more gravitas and maybe more able
to shift public opinion one way or the
other than the more cynical generation
today looks at the current royal family,
but at the time that's about the extent
of their political authority.
Parliament,
the legislature of Britain has the power
then like they have the power now,
but that creates a dynamic where the
French and the British have to worry
about things that,
you know,
the countries on the other side of the
ledger or Russia don't have to worry
about.
They have to worry about the political
situation.
They have to worry about their political
opponents.
You know,
using the war situation as a political
issue in Great Britain.
There's quite a bit of division over
this whole thing and during this time
period between when the archduke is
assassinated,
which happens on June 28th,
1914,
and when the Austria,
Hungarian government issues that famous
ultimatum,
the list of demands to Serbia,
which happens on July 23rd,
there's a big dead zone in there.
No,
it's not really a dead zone.
If you were reading the morning papers
every morning in that period,
there'll be war scares and comments here
and there'd be something new everyday to
keep you focused on the crisis.
But historically speaking,
not much happens.
What was going on was behind the scenes,
a ton of diplomacy and one of the main
avenues of diplomacy or the French
trying to get the British,
you know,
into some sort of hard agreement for
what they're going to do if this war
breaks out in five minutes because they
don't have a hard agreement with the
British.
They sort of have a soft agreement
instead of a signed on the dotted line
contract.
They have a handshake deal and they're
starting to get a little bit worried
about the handshake deal and they're
getting worried that even if the
government in charge in London right now
will come through on the handshake deal,
who's to say they're going to be able to
keep political power.
Their opponents could use this war
issue,
you know,
to topple the government,
take control of the government,
and then say to France,
we only have a handshake deal.
I'm sorry,
the new government will not comply with
a handshake deal.
Sorry,
we're not getting involved in this war.
We're neutral.
We have this splendid isolation and the
navy will protect us because remember,
folks,
look at a map of Great Britain.
They have a giant moat around their
country and the greatest navy in the
world to protect it.
They have the option of staying out of
this thing if they want to.
The French don't have that luxury.
They run the invasion list there on the
dinner menu for imperial Germany and
they're looking for people to provide
some help.
They've got the Russians,
but the Russians are a long way away,
but not being on the dinner menu for the
imperial German military meant that the
British situation was fundamentally
different.
They couldn't see a real positive
outcome for them if they get involved in
this whole affair.
I mean there are things the French can
gain.
They've got a couple of last territories
they lost to Germany and the war of 18,
78 and 71.
They'd like to get those back in a best
case scenario,
you know,
if this conflict breaks out,
they will get them back.
The British don't have anything that
wonderfully positive to look forward to.
Yes,
they might alleviate the threat of this
German fleet,
but by 1912 it was already felt that the
British had proven that the Germans
could not compete with them in the
building of ships,
not if they wanted to have a great land
army at the same time.
And so that's kind of out of the way by
this point.
So no big gain there.
And maybe you protect France from
falling because if France falls,
you get the situation you had in the
Second World War in 1940,
we're all of a sudden you have the
German staring across the English
Channel from you and then all of a
sudden that moat doesn't look that wide
does it,
but that's not a lot of positive stuff
to go into the first global conflict in
100 years for to the British.
This looks like a massive disruption of
their extremely profitable business
ventures.
They've been snapping up books like the
great illusion written by Norman Angle
where every historian points out how
influential this book was,
where angle is trying to explain to the
people in that time period that this war
that continually gets threatened,
like the Russian roulette trigger being
pulled is never going to happen.
It can't happen.
The world has become to interdependent
in that time period.
There's too much globalization.
This is the early period where all that
starts where you have the telegraph,
providing instant communication and the
railroads on the shipping lines and
trade had never been higher.
Wealth had never been grander and Europe
was at the height of its financial power
and Britain was at the height of
everybody's financial power.
Why would you mess with that economic
situation?
Guys like angle?
We're saying that what had happened is
it was so profitable to simply do
business as usual that there was nothing
worth going to war over.
What angle was saying is that anything
you would gain by launching a war would
be dwarfed by what you would lose by
destroying the system that was allowing
everyone to make so much money.
There's an old line,
um,
that when goods don't cross borders,
armies will.
Well,
this is the opposite situation.
Their goods are crossing borders like
crazy.
So guys like angle tell you that,
you know,
because of that formula and they believe
in that formula.
You can't have a war with the British
are starting to find out,
you know,
as this dead zone period from the end of
the arch,
Duke's assassination to the ultimate
unbiased Serbia.
What the British are starting to find
out is that angle is at least partially
wrong.
He may be right.
That you will destroy a whole system
that's making everybody rich.
He seems to be wrong in thinking that
the powers that be will avoid a war
because of that and the British
government is having a hard time selling
their people on the idea that this is
good for Britain.
On July 23rd,
finally the long awaited response from
the Austro-hungarian government to the
killing of their heir to the throne.
They send an ultimatum that to the
government of Serbia and the ultimatum
is one of those documents you can look
at throughout history that is obviously
designed to be rejected.
The demands would eviscerate Serbian
sovereignty,
no sovereign state could agree to this,
and they're only given 48 hours to
respond to all these different points.
The rejection of any one of which means
war.
But the day before the 48 hour deadline
runs out,
the Serb government sends a message to
the czar of Russia asking for help,
and they wrote,
quote,
we cannot defend ourselves.
Therefore we pray.
Your Majesty descend help as soon as
possible.
Your Majesty has given many proofs of
your previous goodwill,
and we confidently hope that this
appeal,
we'll find an echo when you're generous,
Slav,
heart and quote,
the Serbs send a response back to the
Austra Hungarians.
It's not good enough.
The declare a war on July,
28th,
exactly one month after the
assassination and they're shelling
Belgrade in like five minutes.
The Russians declare mobilization in
response to this.
This is the moment when the first
outside power turns on their doomsday
device is when the Austra Hungarians and
the Serbians mobilize.
It doesn't freak anyone else out because
they're going to fight a little war
against each other and they have to
mobilize to do that.
It's when the first outside power tied
to these alliance systems,
flicks on their doomsday device that
everyone else is going to feel the
pressure to do the same thing.
Germany,
the most pressure because they're the
ones with the very short window of
opportunity.
I think the designer of the military
plans count.
Schlieffen had figured out it was about
900,
950 hours that they had to smash the
potential of France.
She didn't have to be mopped up,
but she had to be smashed within 950 or
so hours before the Russians would start
to come in from the east with their
armies now mobilize.
If you screwed that up,
they could be in Berlin and having
coffee and cigarettes and poking the
Kaiser with a stick in a cage.
By the time you know,
the Germans figured out what was going
on,
so the minute the Russians mobilize,
you have this crisis because the
Russians have the flexibility.
If they want to have just sending those
people home in a month.
Mobilization doesn't mean more to them,
but it does to the Germans because
they've got to start their plans and
every day they don't.
That 950 or so,
our window is shrinking.
This is the point in the story where the
military plans begin to take over the
political process in a way that makes it
impossible for the politicians and the
diplomat to do what they need to do to
potentially stop this conflict.
They need time.
On the 26th of July,
the government of Britain calls a peace
conferences for the major powers that
they could hash this out,
talk it out.
Nobody's got the time.
Once the Russians hit the mobilization
switch,
the Germans are under pressure.
They tell the Russians to stop.
The Russians say,
we're only doing this against Austria,
Hungary.
This isn't meant.
You know,
against you.
Doesn't matter.
The Germans have a problem now,
and they begin going to everyone else
and saying,
are you in?
Are you in?
They go to the French.
Let me say to the French,
are you in this conflict that's about to
come out because we're going to go to
war with the Russians.
If they don't demobilize,
what are you going to do?
The French,
we're going to act in accordance with
our interest from the German said,
well,
listen,
if you want to stay out of this war,
all you have to do is hand us the keys
to all your faults on are fortified
border until the war in the east is
over.
That says a pledge of your good behavior
and we'll consider you out of this war.
That is impossible for the French
government to do as the demands on
Serbia war for the Serbians to do fringe
can't do that.
That's an handover.
Your national security keys to your most
antagonistic historic enemy.
I don't think so,
and the Germans must have known that
they knew they couldn't keep France out
of this conflict,
which is why they had these fantastic
military plans to defeat,
to powers the country they were really
hoping to keep out of the conflict was
Great Britain when they kept negotiating
with Britain saying,
you know,
you don't have any deal here.
We're cousins.
We're both Anglo saxons were the same
race.
You know the French are your historic
enemies.
Are you really going to work with them?
On the 30th of July,
the British prime minister wrote in his
diary,
quote,
the European situation is at least one
degree worse than it was yesterday and
it has not been improved by a rather
shameless attempt on the part of Germany
to buy our neutrality during the war by
promises that she will not annex French
territory except colonies or Holland or
Belgium.
There is something very crude he writes
and childlike about German diplomacy.
Meanwhile,
the French are beginning to press in the
opposite sense as the Russians have been
doing for some time the city he means
London,
which is in a terrible state of
depression and paralysis is for the time
being all against English intervention.
I think the prospect very black today
and to quote,
but something will happen that will
change the mood in Britain.
Something that will help to create a
good guy,
bad guy narrative in this war.
You know,
as I told you earlier,
one of the key issues,
because this war is so important to the
rest of the 20th century in 21st century
history is whose fault at all is and the
British are very concerned during this
time period that they be.
If they intervene,
intervening on the right side,
who's the bad guy?
It's going to depend on what happens.
That's again where the German war plans
put them in a situation where for the
war plan to succeed,
you have to create strategic problems
that are going to cost you the war.
The biggest thing the Germans need to do
here is keep the British out of this
war,
but the war plans involve a requirement
that will bring the British into the
war.
The Germans can't attack the French
along their mutual border.
That border is full of forts.
It's the most one of the most fortified
borders throughout world history ever
since Roman times.
It's the same area,
but 120 mile front that will become the
Maginot line after this war and before
the Second World War.
During this time period,
there are fantastically technologically
sophisticated forts all through this 120
mile border between Germany and France
with interlocking fields of fire and
large garrison's.
It's not that the Germans can't defeat
that.
They did in 18,
70 18,
71.
That was the root of invasion back then.
The problem is the Germans can't defeat
them within that 950 or so.
Our window,
by the time the German smashed their way
through those forts,
the Russians are in Berlin and Silesia
and everywhere else.
Right?
So there's only one thing the Germans
can see their way to doing as part of
this plan to win the two front and
that's
just smashed into France and the part of
France that's undefended,
but the reason the part of France that's
undefended or less defended than this
fortified border is less defendant is
because it isn't on the border with
Germany,
so on the border with a bunch of neutral
states,
these are going to have to be the
highways the German army uses to get
from Germany to France.
The only problem is is that those
highways neutrality is guaranteed by the
British government and has been for 75
years.
What is about to happen as a result of
the stipulations of those German war
plans is potentially the greatest
mistake ever made.
I mean,
I'd put it on my top 10 list somewhere.
Greatest mistakes ever made,
and if you're a German,
I have to believe that I have a hard
time figuring out what is a greater
mistake for the entire history of your
nation as a unified country since 18,
71.
I have a hard time finding something you
could label as a greater mistake than
this one because so many of the other
candidates you might put as your
greatest mistake only happened because
of this mistake before it.
The invasion of Belgium is a disaster
for Germany on so many fronts and that's
what we're talking about here.
Originally,
way back in like the late 18 hundreds,
early 19 hundreds.
Holland had also been on the list of
countries to be used as a highway for
the German army.
But since that time and as the war plans
were refined,
it was just narrowed down to just
Belgium and the Germans were sort of
naively hoping that the Belgians would
just step aside,
like line their army up on both sides of
the street and watched the Germans
marched through.
Um,
the British and the Russians,
you know,
who are sort of the forefathers of these
Germans were two of the signatories to
something called the Treaty of London in
1839 that pledged to defend Belgium's
neutrality
in a wonderfully tragic,
ironic sort of connection to,
by the way,
the role Belgium is going to play
leading to the first world war is very
similar to the role Poland played
leading up to the second in both cases,
those countries where the reason Britain
got dragged into the conflict before the
Second World War,
Britain had tried to stop Hitler's
seemingly endless ambition by putting a
roadblock in his way in guaranteeing the
independence of Poland.
Hitler ignored that guarantee went into
Poland and Britain's and the war in the
first world war.
The same thing is happening with
Belgium.
The German planners can see no way to
win this war without violating Belgium's
neutrality.
As we said,
this is what makes it the greatest
mistake though potentially in all German
history because violating Belgium ends
up taking a Britain that one historian
says as recently as two days before they
declare war on Germany is leaning toward
neutrality.
That's amazing to think about two days
before they enter the war,
the government is leaning toward
neutrality.
What changed that?
The invasion of Belgium,
the invasion of Belgium does to terrible
things.
If you're looking at this from Germany's
point of view,
the first thing is changes.
British,
political and public opinion,
almost overnight on a dime
as the British prime minister,
Herbert Asquith put it.
He of course wants to get more involved
in this looming war because of the
handshake deal with France.
He said that the ultimatum,
the Germans give to the Belgians,
simplify matters.
All of a sudden the people who are
trying to convince the rest of Britain
that they have a dog in this continental
war looming up have some real
ammunition.
The first thing is a signed treaty with
the Belgians.
That's not a handshake deal that's in
inc and its long standing as is the
national security concern that Britain
has had for a very long time of keeping
the channel ports in Belgium out of the
hands of some dangerous,
hostile power throughout most of
Britain's history.
That dangerous hostile power was France,
but they're calling the kaiser,
the new Napoleon,
and if he goes into Belgium,
he's going to have those channel ports.
So what had been a more sort of high
brow,
a argument that didn't really appeal to
the gut is changing because of Belgium.
The most important appeal to the gut
though that Belgium has is the
propaganda slash pr side of this whole
thing.
Belgium is what destroys Germany's
reputation in terms of global public
opinion.
I mean there'd always been people who
called Germany,
this evil malevolent,
militaristic country and what have you
been on the world stage as soon as the
Germans invaded Belgium,
they participate in the most aggressive
act so far by any of the major powers in
this conflict.
Austro-Hungarian assault against Serbia
maybe before this was the most
egregious,
but that was seen as having some sort of
connection to events.
I mean the Serbian government had maybe
been involved in this assassination.
There was something to do with one
another.
Belgium was an innocent bystander,
you know,
it's like a shooting war breaks out
between a couple of of gangsters on the
street and the first thing one of the
gangsters does is turn to the side and
kills an innocent bystander because
they're standing in their way.
That's a little like what this is
portrayed as by,
you know,
the allied propaganda services which
make the most use of this Belgium thing
you can imagine.
So much so that it incense,
people like off Hitler who will write
later in mind comp that nowhere else
did.
The Germans,
you know,
fall so far behind the British and the
French later the Americans than they did
in the.
In the realm of propaganda.
Hitler says the huge mistake of Germany
and Austria,
Hungary is propaganda was to portray the
enemy as comical.
And he said that the British and the
French,
the Americans understand that the enemy
needs to be seen as vile and dangerous
and blood thirsty and is bad.
Not Comical because he said the problem
with portraying them as comical as you
run up against them and they're tough
and that seems to shatter all the
propaganda.
It's better to say they're these evil,
you know,
the nine riders have more door are
approaching.
He says,
and then you know,
you really get your back into a cause
like that and how the allies,
which is what Britain,
France and many other countries,
the United States later included,
will be called in this war there
initially called the triple entente.
The other side,
the alliance with Germany,
Austria,
hungry.
Later Turkey and some other countries
will be called the central powers.
And so it's the triple entente against
the central powers or the allies against
the central powers.
And the central powers will be portrayed
just as Hitler said,
as these rapers and pillagers and
looters and it will be in Belgium.
That the Germans will provide their
opponents with the raw materials to not
have to exaggerate too much at all to
portray them as the modern day version
of the huns.
Now on August first 19,
14,
this small war between the ostrow
Hungarians and the Serbs gets bigger
because that's when the German ultimatum
given to the Russians telling them to
stop their mobilization or else runs
out.
Historian David Stevenson says that this
is a clear sign that the Russians know
what's coming and they're okay with it.
They know that if they don't stand down,
they'll have war with Germany and they
don't stand down,
so he says one way or another,
you have to infer that the Russians were
ready for this and okay with it.
So on August first,
the Germans declare war on the Russians
that day.
Italy says they're out.
They had a nominal alliance with Germany
and Austria,
Hungary,
but they choose to use an out clause
which may or may not be valid depending
on who you're talking to,
saying that this appears to be an
aggressive war and their alliance only
covers defensive war,
so they're out.
They declared that they are neutral in
this new conflict.
It's just starting the next day in the
West.
Germany invades the neutral country of
Luxembourg,
the tiny little neutral country of
Luxembourg.
And at the same time issues this
ultimatum to the Belgians saying,
listen,
we just need to use your country to get
to France.
Uh,
we mean you no harm.
Just let us march through.
If we break anything,
we'll pay for it later and we don't have
any designs on your country longterm in
response to this.
The Belgians have a heroic moment where
the king of Belgium,
you know,
and,
and the major officials all get together
and basically all agree that they're not
going to stand down.
The attitude they seem to have is we're
screwed either way.
We might as well go out of this
gloriously and they decide to mobilize
their tiny little army and fight and at
the same time issue the calls to the
other guarantors of their neutrality
saying,
um,
you know,
and they waited until the moment the
Germans,
by the way,
stepped in.
Everybody's worried that somebody's
going to pull a fast one and try to feel
like that the French are worried the
Germans are going to try to fake them
into going into Belgium first because
they think the Germans are coming in and
then the Germans can say,
we weren't the first people to violate
Belgium.
Everybody wants to stay on the good side
in terms of war,
responsibility.
The French are so worried about falling
into a trap like that.
They pulled unprecedented move of all
time and on the eve of war,
pulled their military forces six miles
back from the border.
Remember,
that's not just forward positioning.
Those are troops who picked the spots
that they were in because they're
important strategic spots,
important passes and river crossings and
other things that have been built up
with fortifications for years and the
French government is so freaked out
about possibly being blamed for starting
this and the Germans not being blamed
for starting this,
that they pull their forces back.
The French generals are not pleased
about this,
but the move is intended to also make
sure that the British people and the
peace faction in Britain have no excuse
to say,
well,
French violated Belgian neutrality
first,
or shots were fired by the French first,
so the Germans are positioned into this
thing where they have a time limit on
this deal.
They can't sit around and wait around.
Belgium has to be violated for the plan
to work.
They can't get the French or the British
to violate Belgium.
First.
They tell the Belgians,
you know,
to let them through the Belgian say no,
and on August third,
Germany declares war on France and
Belgium.
Now think about that folks.
A week ago,
Europe was peaceful.
Now it's on the slide to general war.
Within another week,
the entire continent is going to be
flaming out at each other.
I mean,
that's crazy to go from total peace to
total war in less than two weeks.
Hg Wells writing a year or two after the
conflict ends.
So He's right in the middle of the
moment.
He even says,
you can't quite,
you know,
you can't write about it now without the
passions and the feelings,
you know,
totally screwing up your impression of
things,
but he does talk about how weird the
mood was because all this was happening
so fast and he was talking about the
British public because that's where he
lived and how there was almost this
disconnect between the fact that the
entire world has changed,
but it's happening so fast we haven't
changed with it yet,
and he writes,
quote,
all Europe still remembers the strange
atmosphere of those eventful sunny
August days.
The end of the armed piece for nearly
half a century,
the western world had been tranquil and
it seemed safe.
Only a few middle aged and ageing people
in France had had any practical
experience of warfare.
The newspapers spoke of a world
catastrophe,
but that conveyed very little meaning to
those for whom the world.
It always seems secure,
who were indeed almost incapable of
thinking of it as anything otherwise
then secure in Britain particularly for
some weeks,
the peace time routine continued in a
slightly dazed fashion.
It wasn't like a man still walking about
the world,
unaware that he has contracted a fatal
disease which will alter every routine
and habit in his life.
People went on with their summer
holidays,
shops,
reassured their customers with the
announcement business as usual.
There was much talk and excitement when
the newspapers came,
but it was the talk and excitement of
spectators have no vivid
sense of participation in the
catastrophe that was presently to
involve them all and quote.
It's easy to understand too,
why the British public really weren't
ready for this.
In fact,
none of the British were really ready
for this.
They hadn't been mentally prepped for
the idea that this was coming for all
sorts of political reasons.
The British government couldn't declare
itself outright and sort of draw a line
in the sand and tell the Germans,
listen,
if you invade Belgium,
it's on no ifs,
ands,
or buts.
The British prime minister didn't have
that power for all he knew the piece
faction in his government would topple
is government.
If a statement like that were made and
both the French and the Germans for a
very long time before this conflict
breaks out,
but especially in the fevered,
you know,
last month are trying to get some sort
of word from Great Britain,
what the policy is,
what are you going to do at the last
minute?
The French are sure the British are
going to abandon them.
The French foreign minister will sit
down and discuss it at one point and say
they're going to desert us and when
someone in the British media asked him,
what are you doing?
He says,
I'm going to wait to see if Britain
still has any honor.
The British are waiting for something to
happen in Belgium and somewhere the
Belgians,
they don't want to do anything until
their actual neutrality is violated.
So they wait until the Germans arrived
when the advance cavalry patrols and
actually some guys on bicycles believed
or non pedal into Belgium and give
notices to the locals that we're sorry
that we have to do this and uh,
everything will be fine.
Just don't cause any trouble.
Don't blow up any bridges.
Don't sabotage any railways,
don't destroy any tunnels,
anything we might need to get from here
to there,
leave all that in place or those will be
considered hostile acts.
As soon as it becomes apparent that
Germans are on Belgian soil,
the king of Belgium basically orders
that all those things be done and then
he contacts the other guarantors of
Belgian neutrality and says,
the Germans are here.
We need your help.
That's when the British draw up the
official sort of ultimatum,
which people have criticized them for.
I mean they say if you don't only give
him that ultimatum before the Germans
had gone into Belgium,
they might've had more options once
they're in Belgium for them to get out
of Belgium because the British told them
to was really like a tail between their
legs kind of situation.
And this has happened in history many
times in other situations where people
have said,
if you had just said what you were going
to do before the enemy did what they did
might've been a different outcome.
In this case,
once the Germans are in Belgium,
the British ambassador to Germany,
a guy named Sir Edward Goshen,
delivers the British ultimatum to
Germany and he delivers it into the
hands of the German minister,
a guy named Godly Vanya Ego,
and the German chancellor,
a guiding theobold bond.
Beckman Halweg and Gosha knew that this
was a historic meeting and he wrote down
what happened and he said the Germans,
when they received this ultimatum from
him,
freaked out.
You wrote that the meeting was fraught
with menace quote.
I found the chancellor very agitated.
His excellence.
He at once began a harangue,
which lasted for about 20 minutes.
He said that the step taken by the
British government was terrible to a
degree just for a word neutrality,
a word which in war time it's so often
been disregarded just for a scrap of
paper.
Great Britain was going to make war on a
kindred nation who desired nothing
better than to be friends with her.
All his efforts in that direction had
been rendered useless by this last
terrible step,
and the policy to which as I knew he had
devoted himself since is a session to
office,
had tumbled down like a house of cards.
What we had done was unthinkable in the
minds of the Germans.
It was like striking a man from behind
while he was fighting for his life
against two assailants.
He yelled Great Britain responsible for
all the terrible events that might
happen.
I protested strongly against that
statement and said that in the same way
that he inherited don Diego wished me to
understand that for strategical reasons,
it was a matter of life and death to
Germany to advance through Belgium and
violate the ladders neutrality,
so I would wish them to understand that
it was so to speak,
a matter of life and death for the honor
of Great Britain,
that she should keep her Solomon
engagements to do our utmost,
to defend Belgium's neutrality if
attacked,
that solemn compact simply had to be
kept or what confidence could anyone
have in engagements given by Great
Britain in the future.
The chancellor said,
but at what price will that compact have
been kept?
As the British government thought of
that and quote,
and this is an interesting key point
because I've often wondered if you could
take the principals who were the
decision makers in this conflict into
the future and show them some history
books and show them what had happened,
even the winners.
Do you think they would've found a way
to avert what ended up happening because
it was more horrible than any of them
envisioned?
The German field marshal in charge of
the military affairs at this time.
Von Moltke famously said that this was
the struggle that would decide the
course of history for the next hundred
years and he was absolutely right.
Maybe more,
but had he known that this would mean
that Germany would be on the losing end
of two World Wars in the 20th century.
What do you think he would have done?
I mean,
look at the situation now and imagine
Germany without having lost those two
world wars and how different they might
be today.
There are German historians who consider
this role of the iron dice as going to
war here is often referred to as one of
the great,
irresponsible gambles in all German
history,
and maybe the key element in the whole
affair was Britain's decision to involve
itself in the conflict because one can
make a very good case that if Britain
stands aside,
Germany wins this war that's about to
start.
Instead,
they have perhaps the greatest overall
superpower in the early 20th century
world lining up on the other side,
and to be truthful,
the Germans weren't really afraid of the
British army.
I mean,
that's a small colonial force that by
German standards is relatively
insignificant or so they think.
I mean bismarck had famously said when
an advisor had warned him that if you go
to war with Britain,
they could use that wonderful naval
power to land their entire army on our
coastline.
And Bismark famously said,
if they do that,
I shall have them arrested.
Meaning he just send the police force
out to corral the British army.
That's how worried they were about this
tiny little force that their army
dwarfed,
but they were keenly aware that Britain
had the greatest navy by far in the
world.
They were the greatest financial power
in the world.
They controlled a huge chunk of the
world.
Britain and France together owned about
70 percent of the world at this time
period when you talk about all their
colonies and everything else,
and that's all stuff that they can draw
on to fight the war.
What's more that wonderful navy have
Great Britain's can shut down German
shipping,
you know,
in a moment at a stroke of a pen,
Britain's foreign secretary Sir Edward
Gray on August third,
19,
14 when tensions have reached a knife
edge fever pitched moment.
We'll look out the window and see the
lamp.
Lighters of London lighting the lamps
for the evening as was customary at the
time,
and he turned to someone else at the
window and famously said,
the lamps are going out all over Europe.
We shall not see them lit again in our
lifetime.
The Germans are given the famous
ultimatum and it's set to expire at
midnight on August fourth German time,
which is 11:00
PM British time.
Lloyd George,
one of the ministers says that they were
sitting around a table just before the
stroke of 11 watching the clock tick
away and he said that his big bands
chime start shiming for the 11:00
hour signifying that the deadline is
about to expire.
He says,
every ring of the bell sounded like
doom,
and then when it expires,
Britain declares war on Germany
and it's worth asking at this point what
the people who adjust,
you know,
entered upon this course of action
thought was going to happen when Lloyd
George,
here's the chimes of big bend sounding
and things.
They sound like doom.
What does Lloyd George mean when he says
doom?
I mean this is a conflict of the sort
that Europe had not had for 100 years
and a lot of changed in 100 years.
This is like a jump off of a cliff in
the dark for Europe and no one knows how
long the drop is going to be and they've
been exposed to a lot of thinking
out there by guys like Norman Angle we
mentioned earlier who were saying no
one's going to jump.
Jumping would be suicidal,
everybody die.
The golden goose would be killed.
Globalization will be destroyed.
No one will do it,
and now they had just done it.
What did people think that meant?
Well,
as we said earlier,
the first world war has so much written
about it that you can share.
We pick from this or that source and
create any sort of impression you want.
What it really looks like though,
if you sum up,
you know,
I've read a bunch of stuff on this and
and to me what it looks like is that
there was a small view amongst some
people that understood the reality and
they turn out to be the Cassandra's in
the story.
The,
the ones who actually prophesies
accurately what's going to happen.
Most of these people didn't have a clue.
I think Lloyd George,
when he hears Big Ben Sounding Doom,
is worried about Britain's financial
sector and he had every reason to be by
the way,
because a few days before when Austria,
Hungary declares war on Serbia,
the markets around the world,
you know,
go crazy,
and in London,
the financial capital of the world,
Lloyd George is hearing from all the
bankers and all the investors and all
these people that this is a crisis.
It will destroy Britain fiscally,
which sounds like the worst thing in the
world until you fast forward the time
machine for years and see what's really
going to happen,
where you would have paid good money to
only have the financial system
collapsed.
Here's the thing though,
there were people who turned out to be
right about how momentous this leap off
this cliff and how long the drop was
going to be,
who turned out to be right and we're
kind of hoping for it.
I mean,
take for example,
the guy who along with Karl Marx helped
create modern communism.
Friedrich Engels who in 18,
87 wrote about this coming conflict and
how terrible it was going to be,
and of course you know in his mind
hoping for an overthrow of all the
existing regimes to be replaced by
communism.
That was sort of the silver lining in
this coming armageddon.
Engels wrote quote,
I see a world war of never before seen
extension and intensity.
If the system of mutual outbidding in
armament carried to the extreme,
finally bears it's natural fruits,
eight to 10 million soldiers will
slaughter each other and strip you're a
bear as no swarm of locusts has ever
done before.
The devastations of the 30 years' war,
condensed into three or four years and
spread all over the continent.
Famine,
epidemics,
General Barbara,
realization of armies and masses
provoked by sheer desperation,
utter chaos in our trade industry and
commerce ending in general bankruptcy
collapse of the old states in their
traditional wisdom in such a way that
the crowns role in the gutter by the
dozens and there'll be nobody to pick
them up.
Absolute impossibility to foresee how
all this will end and who will be the
victors in that struggle.
Only one result,
absolutely certain general exhaustion
and the creation of circumstances for
the final victory of the working and
quote,
so there's your silver lining.
If you happen to be a communist
revolutionary and you want to see the
overthrow of governments and in one
sense angles will get what he wants,
at least in one country,
but he's not the only person that
precedes this.
Some of the best military minds of the
time.
See it too.
We've told you about the field marshal
in charge of Germany's war effort,
the man known as von Moltke,
but he is a pale shadow of his uncle,
the man known as the elder von Moltke,
who commanded Prussian forces in the
Franco Prussian war of 1878 slash 71 by
this time period.
He's retired and he's on the speaking
circuit in 1906.
He speaks to the German legislature and
he warns them what a modern war is going
to be like.
The age of cabinet war is behind us.
All we have now is people's war.
Gentlemen,
if the war that has been hanging over
our heads now for more than 10 years,
like the sword of Damocles,
if this war breaks out,
then its duration and its end will be
unforeseeable,
the greatest powers of Europe armed as
never before,
we'll be going into battle with each
other,
not one of them can be crushed so
completely in one or two campaigns that
it will admit defeat,
that it will be compelled to conclude
piece under hard terms and that it will
not come back even if it is a year later
to renew the struggle.
Gentlemen,
it may be a wharf seven years or 30
years duration and woe to him who sets
Europe a light,
who first puts the fuse to the powder
keg and quote,
this long drop in the dark is going to
set up the first.
If you want to use the boxing analogy
again,
the first heavyweight championship fight
the world has seen since Napoleon stay
100 years before.
In the interim,
you've had a lot of,
you know,
one sided conflicts.
You know a champion like Muhammad Ali or
Mike Tyson fighting a person you've
never heard of,
or you'll have something like the wars
between the United States and Spain over
Cuba and the Philippines,
which is a rising soon to be first class
power against a declining soon to be
third class power or these great
colonial conflicts.
We're a nation like Britain will go in
and crush the dervishes or the Zulus
with the occasional setback of course,
and they will use machine guns against
these natives.
Armed with spears,
one of these machine guns,
really a gatling gun was called the
maximum gun and there was a famous
colonial era poem that said,
whatever happens,
we have got the maximum gun and they
have not in this upcoming war.
Both sides will have the maximum gun.
In fact,
much more deadly modern versions of the
maxim gun that we call machine guns
today.
No one had ever seen a war where both
sides had machine guns.
The Franco Prussian war saw the French
trying to use these gatling guns,
these early machine guns as best they
could,
but no one really had any clue what to
do with them.
That had all changed by 1914.
We were seeing most professional armies
perhaps that the world had ever seen and
certainly the largest that the world had
ever seen,
getting ready to clash in a conflict
that was going to be like jumping off a
cliff in the dark.
Nobody could foresee the end of this.
One thing was for sure the army for
Germany that is about to enter Belgium
is probably the greatest army that the
world had seen up until that time,
and I say that with everyone knowing
what a big fan I am of the Mongol,
a military science and history and their
armies and they're wonderful,
but they get respect.
People understand how incredibly
dominant the Mongols were.
The army of Germany during this time
period,
the Kaiser,
right?
This is like the Rodney Dangerfield of
armies.
They don't get any respect,
and yet they are maybe.
I mean,
you create your top 10 list of the
greatest armies throughout all history,
and I put the Kaiser Right Carme on
there.
I'm not sure I put the German army from
the Second World War on there and yet
part of the reason we don't know more
about that first World War German armies
because the Second World War German
army,
like so many things in that second
conflict overshadow it in many ways.
The Wehrmacht in the Second World War is
flashier than the first World War German
army,
you know,
once again,
to get to the box and character
Richard's the Wehrmacht is a big heavy
hitter knockout artist and they go
around and it's just boom,
it's over in one round sometimes and you
stand up and it's thrilling and
incredible,
but you know,
once someone hits them back or or beats
them up a little,
it's a different game and once you start
wearing them down,
now you can continue to wear them down
because they're not strong.
Fundamentally at the core,
they have a great punch,
but they rest sort of on an uneven
foundation.
That was really where the strength of
the first World War army was.
It may not have been as flashy with
those giant knockouts and all that,
but they had a better chin and they
were,
you know,
they rested on from foundations.
It was a fantastic army and no one
remembers it today,
and what's funny is once again,
it just becomes another thing that I'd
off Hitler was wrong about when he
wrote,
quote,
thousands of years may pass,
but never will it be possible to speak
of heroism without mentioning the German
army in the world war.
Then from the veil of the past,
the iron front of the gray steel helmet
will emerge unwavering and unflinching
and immortal monument as long as there
are Germans alive.
They will remember that these men were
sons of their nation.
And to quote,
it's a fantastic army and part of what
makes it so great is this natural
efficiency that was almost
stereotypically German,
is applied to military science during a
time period where military science
really does become science.
It's become the age of the bean counters
and efficiency experts when it comes to
putting an army in the field.
That's what the Napoleonic era creates,
where you get this first part of the war
machine,
the ability to create these mass armies.
Now imagine a guy like Alexander the
great who I love to mention all the
time,
but you can imagine Julius Caesar to
guys who probably never commanded more
than 80,000
people ever and who staffs,
you know we're capable and they could
deal with it and they were very
efficient logistically and everything
for their time period,
but they were dealing with 80,000
men in this era.
You're dealing with 12 to 15 times that
amount.
What would alexander the great had done
trying to,
you know,
control one and a half million men.
It's an exercise in higher math to try
to do that.
And when you hear about how the Germans
had prepared minute Lee for this day,
that for so long had been called the day
dare tog this attack into Belgium into
overwhelm friends and everything.
You get an idea of how much actual bean
counting and planning is involved now in
order to maintain these armies.
That would have been impossible 150
years before because this capability
didn't exist.
It's,
it's a function of modern civilization
and the era of the 20th century.
Now you get an idea of size.
You have to think about the division,
which is the basic unit that these
militaries kinda operate with.
It goes back to Napoleonic times.
Divisions are still used of course in
military is today,
and if you want to think about 15,000
men in a division as a kind of a rough
size,
it actually fluctuates in different
militaries and whatnot,
but just think 15,000
men,
a $15,000
million division is probably more troops
than either the normans or the saxons
had at the battle of hastings,
the pivotal 10,
66 panel that decided the fate of
Britain at the time,
England at the time.
So each division,
this is equivalent to a rather nice
sized early medieval army.
The German army at the beginning of the
war has more than 80 of these.
Imagine trying to control 80 norman
armies and it's not just about getting
each division where it needs to go.
It's about sinking what they do
together.
When you start organizing divisions and
two cores and cores into armies,
then these armies have to support each
other.
They have to travel on different roads
and then converge at certain points and
you have to think of the incredible math
that's involved in these march columns
and it's hard to get your mind around,
but these units are so large and these
roads so narrow that when the head of
the column starts walking,
they've gone like 29 miles before the
end of the column can start walking.
Trying to plan to have food ready for
these guys when they stopped marching
and I mean it's the logistics of this is
incredible and it's the main reason why
you couldn't do this,
you know,
ages and ages ago.
You just couldn't support it.
In addition to all these armies are
fabulously trained.
The Germans are incredibly trained in
terms of having even they're reservists
on the practice fields in Germany doing
live fire exercises.
Preparing for this day.
This is what Barbara Tuchman writes
about,
you know,
it starts with mobilization and you get
an idea of how planned every step is.
In the German army quote,
once the mobilization button was pushed,
the whole vast machinery for calling up,
equipping and transporting,
2 million men began turning
automatically.
Reservists went to their designated
Depos,
were issued uniforms,
equipment and arms formed into companies
and companies into battalions were
joined by cavalry,
cyclists,
artillery,
medical units,
cook wagons,
blacksmith wagons,
even postal wagons moved according to
prepared railway timetables to
concentration points near the frontier
where they would be formed into
divisions,
into cores and cores into armies,
ready to advance and fight.
One Army Corps alone,
she writes out of the total of 40 in the
German forces,
required a hundred and 70 railway cars
for officers,
965 for infantry,
2,960
for cavalry.
Nineteen hundred and 15 for artillery
and supply wagons.
Six thousand and 10 in all grouped in
140 trains and an equal number.
Again for their supplies.
From the moment the order was given,
she writes,
everything was to move at fixed times
according to a schedule precise down to
the number of train axles that would
pass over a given bridge within a given
time.
And to quote,
when you realize how my noodly planned
and how you know,
punctual,
this whole thing must be in order to
function.
You can see why delays of even a few
hours.
We'll throw your whole timetable off.
You know,
right before this whole conflict breaks
out,
and I mentioned it earlier,
the Kaiser will turn to von Moltke and
he's panicking at the last minute.
The Great Supreme Warrior leaders,
not so tough when it all looks like it's
coming down.
Unfortunately for him or fortunately for
him,
the staff that works under him are tough
as nails.
Again,
another thing is German army,
this period brought to the table,
which to be honest,
the second one did most of the time too.
It's fantastic leadership and the Kaiser
at one point thinks the war was
Britain's off and he says,
great,
we can turn the armies around,
you know,
just send them to Russia instead of
worrying about France and England at
all,
and von Moltke has to stop him and say,
you do not improvise the deployment of
millions.
I think the exact line was the
deployment of millions cannot be
improvised,
but you get the point.
This was a,
an efficient plan to deploy the largest
number of people that had ever been sent
in a single area for a single purpose.
Probably in all human history.
You think about Napoleon's greatest
outrageous gamble,
right?
To invade Russia,
utilizing an army composed of many,
many,
many different European peoples.
You know,
he had to scrape Germany and every place
else to get enough people to send into
Russia with something that was called
the grand army.
You know,
in the early 18 hundreds,
and it was this crazy endeavor sent
maybe 750,000
men into the Germans were going to
invade Belgium with more than twice that
in and outflanking maneuver.
That's not even the army.
That's holding the front,
that's just a big wide swinging gate
that's going to smash on top of the head
of France.
How do you control that many people?
How do you even get them from one place
to another?
We kind of seem to think in our head
that they can just march across,
you know,
mountain sides and country lanes and
through fields and pastures and
sometimes they do,
but most of the time they get to places
the same way most of us do.
They utilize the road system.
Think about what the road system in
Belgium,
tiny little,
mostly rural Belgium is going to be like
with this massive greatest sized army
probably ever put together trying to
march through it all in a short period
of time.
There were witnesses,
of course,
to this actually happening.
One of the fun ones to read for me is
Richard Harding Davis because Davis is
one of those guys.
He's an American.
He also,
you know,
he's basically the war correspondent,
uh,
one of the main ones of his era and he
wrote about the deployment of American
forces in Cuba.
You know,
at the turn of the century and all this
kind of stuff and he's,
he's really a Rah Rah America Kinda guy.
You know,
Americans the best at everything and,
and that sort of feeling.
But he was there in Belgium as the
German army comes through and you can,
I mean,
I'm going to read you this extensively
because you can hear in his writing,
his jaw is on the floor and here's
someone who doesn't think anybody does
anything better than America and he's
getting a lesson in what the best army
in the world looks like.
And remember this kind of force at this
kind of level and potency hasn't been on
display in anyone's living memory.
You're getting a view of a nation at war
like you in Napoleonic times,
but marched and equipped and organized
and supported by a modern 20th century
state.
This was while you were beginning to see
a tiny little glimmer of what the leap
in the dark was going to entail.
It was going to entail fighting armies
like this one.
Richard Harding Davis writes,
quote,
the entrance of the German army into
Brussels has lost the human quality.
It was lost as soon as the three
soldiers who led the army bicycled into
the boulevard,
do resent and ask the wage of the ged
ignored when they passed the human note
past with them what came after them,
and 24 hours later,
it's still coming,
is not men marching,
but a force of nature like a tidal wave,
an avalanche,
or a river flooding it's banks at this
minute.
It is rolling through Brussels as the
swollen waters of the valleys swept
through Johnstown at the site of the
first few regiments of the enemy.
He writes,
we were thrilled with interest.
After three hours,
they had passed in one unbroken steel
gray column.
We were bored,
but when hour after hour passed and
there was no,
no breathing time,
no open spaces in the ranks.
The thing became uncanny,
inhuman.
You returned to watch it,
fascinated.
It held the mystery and menace of fog
rolling towards you across the sea and
quote.
He then goes on to describe the
uniforms,
which are pretty much the same color.
The Second World War German uniforms are
felled Grau,
I guess is the proper way to pronounce
it,
but basically it's just a gray,
but during this time period,
most nations had only relatively
recently gone away from Gadi,
colorful clothing,
you know,
bright red scarlet for British troops
has only recently given away to khaki
and the French army still war stuff that
looked like they belong in Napoleon's
army,
right?
They're going to wear red pants and blue
jackets and they're going to carry
savers and their calvary is going to
have breast plates and horse hair
helmets.
I mean,
it's Kooky stuff.
Most militaries are moving away from
that.
The German's use of gray harting thinks
is the most fantastic use of camouflage
she's ever seen.
The British Khaki is often compared to a
coronary that's gotten.
Dusty Davis goes on and on about how the
minute these German soldiers get 100
yards from you,
you can't see him anymore.
He says he was watching some German
cavalry would ride by and he could see
the horses,
but he couldn't see the guys on them
because they just sort of blend with the
fog and the mist and the twilight and
the early morning hours in that color.
If he goes on and on about how great
that is and how scientific it is,
he goes on quote yesterday,
Major Gen Vaughan,
Zeratsky,
the German military governor of
Brussels,
assured burger master Max,
that the German army would not occupy
the city but would pass through it.
It is still passing.
I have followed in campaigns six armies,
but accepting not even our own,
the Japanese or the British.
I have not seen one so thoroughly
equipped.
I'm not speaking of the fighting
qualities of any army,
only have the equipment in organization.
The German army moved into this city as
smoothly and as compactly as the Empire
State Express,
there were no halts,
no open places,
no stragglers.
This army he writes,
has been on active service for three
weeks and so far there is not apparently
a chin strap or a horseshoe missing.
It came in with the smoke pouring from
cookstoves on wheels and in an hour had
set up post office wagons from which
Mountain Messengers galloped along the
line of columns distributing letters and
at which soldiers posted picture
postcards.
The infantry he writes,
came in files of five to 100 men to each
company,
the lancers in columns of four with not
a pendant missing the quick firing.
Guns and field pieces were one hour at a
time in passing each gun.
It's ammunition wagon taking 20 seconds
in which to pass the men of the infantry
saying,
father land my father land between each
line of song.
They took three steps.
At times 2000 men were singing together
and absolute rhythm and beat.
When the melody gave way,
the silence was broken only by the stamp
of iron shod boots,
and then again the song rose.
When the singing ceased,
the bands played marches.
They were followed by the rumble of
siege guns,
the creaking of wheels and have chains
clanking against the cobblestones and
the sharp bell like voices of the Bugles
for seven hours.
The army passed in such solid columns
that not once might have taxi cab or
trolley car passed through the city like
a river of steel.
It flowed gray and ghostlike.
Then as dusk came in,
as thousands of horses hooves and
thousands of iron boots continued to
tramp forward,
they struck tiny sparks from the
cobblestones,
but the horses and men who beat out the
sparks were invisible.
At midnight,
pack wagons and siege guns were still
passing.
At seven this morning,
I was awakened by the tramp of men in
bands playing jauntily.
Whether they marched all night or not,
I do not know,
but now for 26 hours,
the gray army has rumbled by with the
mystery of fog and the purchase of a
steam roller.
And to quote that was a long quote,
but that's.
That's the German army of the Kaiser,
right on campaign,
the German army and the Second World War
is that country's best attempt to
recreate that.
No,
I've always believed that the very
ferocity in the scariness of this Kaiser
Rack,
German army worked against it at the
beginning of the war in a way that heard
it throughout the entire history of the
war and I think long afterwards helped
establish this German reputation as sort
of the bad guys because this army was so
intimidating,
so scary.
Everything from the precision drill to
the equipment to how well organized they
were to the logistics,
to the leadership,
to the intimidating elements built into
it.
I mean they had a wonderful a unit
called the death's head has SARS,
which goes back to,
you know the Napoleonic wars earlier
actually and they were the old fashioned
Hassan for helmet.
This is in 1914 folks.
This isn't an 18 tend the for helmet of
the CSRS and on the helmet is a skull.
Reminds you a little bit of the SS
forces in the Second World War,
but it shows you that all of this
predated.
You know,
what the Nazis did.
The Nazi's were just updating a lot of
classic German traditions and in a lot
of cases perverting them and sustaining
them with blackness and everything,
but to deaths had his.
Ours are famous and intimidating as
they're meant to be,
but then you take that really nasty for
Roche's,
intimidating army that looks like it
could take on anyone in the world and
the first time you see him in action
they're taking on,
God bless them.
The Belgians,
a tiny little neutral nation that's less
than 100 years old and has never fought
a war in fact is so small and it's
surrounded by great powers that they
rationally figured out a long time ago.
It doesn't matter how much effort they
put into defense,
they can't win.
You know,
the Belgians totally unprepared for
warfare lose only a little bit faster
than the Belgians obsessively prepared
for warfare.
They put their trust in these
international agreements they had with
people who are going to guarantee their
security,
which is how this whole thing is
happening anyway.
Right?
But they did build some defenses maybe
as a sign that,
you know,
we can't kill you,
but we could hurt you and the defenses
are really cool because it's really
right in that period in human history.
We're fortifications,
forts reach,
sort of their high watermark.
I mean we still build for today,
but it's nothing like it was what pretty
much from the beginning of your human
history until.
Well about the time we're talking about
here because then you could base an
entire defense strategy on Ford's.
Nowadays we have these special positions
where your guard them with a fort,
but if anybody decides they're going to
start launching missiles and bombs and
I'm.
It doesn't matter for us.
Don't hold up.
That's something we learn very soon in
this story.
But in the 18 eighties when these
Belgian forts are built,
this is the period where it looks like
modern tech is going to make these
things like space age.
That's something out of Star Wars,
one of those planetary defenses.
And they build these wonderful
subterranean forts.
Barbara Tuchman said like castles,
sunk underground.
And what they'll do is,
you know,
I'm reminded of the old,
a Godzilla films and the monster zero
films where you'd have some planet and
it would have a gun that would just rise
up from the planet surface shoot and
then go back down under ground.
And that's what happened in these
boards.
And I have to remind myself how cool
that is.
This is like steam punk stuff because
when they're building these forts for
Belgium,
it's the same time that the United
States and Mexico are trying to corral
Geronimo and a bunch of Apaches in the
American southwest while that's going
on.
The Belgians are building underground
forts.
And you can see some of the stuff on
video.
If you look at the Maginot line,
which comes a generation after this
obviously,
but it's the same kind of thing where,
you know,
if you look at it from above ground,
you can barely tell there's a fort there
when in fact underground,
you know,
massive concrete and you know,
little railroads underneath moving guns
and ammunition around it.
It's,
it's cool stuff.
And the way the Belgian designer,
who was one of the best in the world,
built this system,
he took advantage of the natural river
and the slight rise in the hill and
everything in there.
And he built six big forts with six
small fortune in between and they all
cover each other's fields of fire with
their guns.
So you know what for a can reach with
their guns,
fort be can reach with,
there's two.
So they overlap.
So there's never a place in the distance
anyway where the guns can't reach the
enemy.
And in between these sports,
the Belgians have it so that they're
going to put guys in trenches.
So between every Ford are people,
they're supported by the guns.
It's this wonderful system.
And then you throw more troops out,
you know,
500 yards,
100 yards ahead to keep enemy artillery
away.
And you have this system where maybe you
can't win a war against someone like the
Germans,
which you give them a bloody nose and
maybe say,
see you,
you really don't want to do this.
Um,
the Germans aren't sure about that.
And when they come into Belgium,
they're kind of thinking the Belgian
armies either just going to stand aside,
like I said earlier,
or maybe you know,
few shots up in the air.
We protected our honor.
Now we're going to stand aside.
And the first sign that the Germans are
wrong about this is that the bridges are
blown up when they get to them,
the tunnels are blown up,
the railroads are blown up that Madden's
the Germans because they're on this
tight schedule,
right?
So now they have to deal with at least
transportation nightmares on this road
system that was already going to be
clogged terribly.
I mean there's your first nightmare.
And then the Germans tried to cross some
of these rivers on the frontier in
pontoons and the Belgian start shooting
at them.
So the Germans put into action a group
that they have designed specifically to
take these forts.
And this is the part of the story.
You have to understand where we are.
When war was declared,
you have like 72 hours where everybody's
trying to get their heads around this
idea.
And at the same time they flipped all
these switches for mobilization.
The doomsday device I called it where
they're calling up all these forces and
everybody,
you know,
we don't have enough stuff here and
everybody's scrambling in what they
assume is a race to the front lines,
which they don't want to lose.
Remember what if they gave a warrant?
Only one side came.
Meanwhile though,
while everybody is concentrating,
it's called their forces.
The Germans have like 30,000
guys that were set up in advance to go
out basically in the pregame of the
first World War,
I guess you could say and take out these
forts if they have to because these
forts are blocking the roads.
You cannot get to that Belgian road
system that you need to get from Germany
to France if you don't take the forts
around a place like leanne or named
Laura.
And so 30,000
men had been training for years for just
this job.
Like I said earlier,
the day was called der Tog the day this
has been planned for for a long time.
And the Germans have essentially a
special unit of 30,000
guys whose job it is to take out these
sports.
If the Belgians don't stand aside and
surrender them,
the Belgians don't stand aside and
surrender them.
And in fact the Belgians are going to
teach the first great lesson of the war,
about what's changed since the last
time.
Great powers faced off how much the
killing power that machine's afforded
mankind on the battlefield.
How much that had changed the age old
equation of war machines had been taken
over for a long time,
becoming more and more important.
This is the war where they take over
completely and man supremacy on the
battlefield,
even though they're the ones who run the
machines,
will always be now you know,
secondary compared to the killing power
and mechanization that can be brought to
bear by modern societies.
The technology was devastating when used
against tribal peoples and nations that
couldn't compete militarily.
The Belgians are going to show what a
tiny little army of chocolate soldiers
is.
What the Germans thought they were going
to face.
What a tiny little army of chocolate
soldiers can do to the greatest army in
the world because of the
deadliness of the weapons at hand,
and one of the interesting sort of sub
themes of this whole upcoming conflict
is how long it takes some people to
absorb the lessons that are being taught
in this conflict.
You know,
lesson number one is how deadly the
weapons are and how you have to account
for that.
Some of the generals and military
thinkers understood this going into the
war because they had paid close
attention to that 19,
oh,
five war I told you about the Russo
Japanese war,
which by the way,
American President Teddy Roosevelt won a
Nobel prize for helping to broker the
piece for that.
But that taught lessons about what
happens when two sides armed with
machine guns and two sides armed with
modern artillery and all that face off.
But the lessons were not the kind of
lesson some people wanted to learn.
I mean,
if you were a cavalry commander,
for example,
your arm of the military is already not
looked upon as very survivable.
The war is all,
since Napoleon have kind of shown that
listened cavalry just dies on the
battlefield.
The only thing that cavalry commander
still have going in their favor is there
aren't really automobiles yet.
There will be by the time this was over,
but they're a novelty.
There'll be used in strange,
innovative situations,
but militaries of the world don't have
tons of automobiles,
you know,
running.
It's not mechanized like the Second
World War.
Everybody's using horses.
Even if they die on the battlefield,
you know,
like sheaves of wheat being sized down.
You have nothing to replace that
mobility with.
But these cavalry commanders don't want
to hear that.
It's even worse than it used to be.
Wow.
Wait until the modern artillery machine
guns get ahold of your cavalry.
They don't want to hear that.
So they talk about the results as being
unrepresentative commanders who were
very,
um,
you know,
involved in the idea of the power of the
bayonet and the charge and the
offensive.
For example,
the entire French outlook on war right
now is connected to this idea that you
attack and you know you attack with the
band.
That doesn't really mean you're gonna,
maybe get into hand to hand combat,
but that aggressive style of warfare is
what you want.
If you've been preaching that and that's
your country's doctrine and your entire
military is organized around the culture
of the offensive and Cran,
which is the French word,
I guess for like guts and it's all about
guts.
Nobody wants to hear that machine guns
just rip the guts out.
That's the only thing they care about
guts and it doesn't work to have bang a
net charges and ridiculous offensives.
Well,
the French would say,
yes,
well what doesn't work for the Russians
or the Japanese will work for the
French,
and that's why we have a great military.
I mean,
there's all kinds of ways to rationalize
what you don't want to learn.
Many of the militaries of the world are
organized like Napoleonic Times.
They don't want to hear that.
That is a completely wrong way to be
organized.
The French cavalry heading off to war,
as I said earlier,
but you have to imagine this,
if you want to see what Nepalian
soldiers looked like,
go look at pictures of the French
cavalry in 1914 going off to war with
metal breastplates and horse hair
helmets,
and you would have to be an expert to
look at a picture of them in 1914 and a
picture of Napoleon's cavalry in 18,
14 and find the differences.
The officers are going to go to war and
white gloves.
They're gonna have swords,
they're gonna.
Stand up and troops are going to march
into combat in like billiard ball
formations or you know,
bowling pin formations,
drill formations from the battlefield.
None of the people who consider this to
be an integral part of military culture.
Want to learn that the rules have
changed.
In 1905.
They got one lesson in 1914.
They were about to get another and the
Germans get there is when they try to
take these forts
on.
August fifth,
19,
14,
the Germans attack four of these Belgian
fourths now between the forts,
the Belgians and quickly put them
infantry and there were a couple of
machine guns around and whatnot and the
Germans,
you know,
they're in a bit of a rush here.
They don't have time to sit there and
starve things out.
This 30,000
man force with artillery has to go in
there and power this through so that the
armies behind them can continue there.
If you just solve through Belgium,
France and they charge these,
you know,
entrenchments and the Belgian slaughter,
them,
slaughter them,
mounds of bodies,
and the Belgians can't figure out the
best way to deal with it because the
mounds of bodies become a problem
because the mountains of bodies become
places German troops can hide behind and
shoot from behind and launch attacks
from behind and the Belgians are trying
to figure out,
okay,
do we shoot through these bodies and
create.
Can you create.
Can you create a whole through bodies if
you shoot through them with a machine
gun long enough,
or do we send out people to risk their
lives to create holes in the bodies that
we can shoot through?
Barbara Tuchman has a passage in her
book where she quotes the commander of
the Belgian forces that were resisting
this German assault by Gen Vaughan,
emic and his Special Brigades Tuckman
writes,
quote
on August Fifth Mx Brigades open to the
attack on the four eastern most forcibly
edge with a cannonade by field
artillery,
followed by an infantry assault.
The light shells made no impression on
the fords,
and the Belgian guns poured a hail of
fire on the German troops.
Slaughtering their front ranks.
Company after company came on making for
the spaces in between.
The forks were the Belgian entrenchments
had not been completed.
At some points where they broke through
the German,
stormed up,
the slopes were the guns could not be
depressed to reach them and were mowed
down by machine guns.
The dead piled up enriches a yard high
at fort boss,
shown Belgians,
seeing the German lines waiver charged
with the bayonet.
And threw them back again and again.
The Germans returned to the assault
spending lives like bullets in knowledge
of plentiful reserves to make up for the
losses.
She now quotes a Belgian officer who was
their quote.
They made no attempt at deploying.
A Belgian officer described it later,
but came on line after line,
almost shoulder to shoulder until we
shot them down.
The fallen were heaped on top of each
other and unlawful barricade of dead and
wounded that threatened to mask our guns
and causes trouble so high to the
barricade become the we didn't know
whether to fire through it or to go out
and clear openings with our hands,
but would you believe it?
This veritable wall of dead and dying
enabled those wonderful Germans to creep
closer and actually charge up the
embankment?
They got no farther than halfway though
because our machine guns and rifles
swept them back.
Of course we had our losses,
but they were slight compared to the
current age we inflicted on our enemies.
And to quote,
it's interesting to note,
isn't it that Belgian officers respect
for those wonderful Germans as he called
them,
exhibiting the military virtues of valor
that were so celebrated during this
period where the romance of warfare,
which had always been strong in human
culture,
was probably at its height,
the 19th century.
The romance was incredible.
This is the era where that romance runs
into reality in a way that you just
can't pretend.
I mean guys like you know William
Tecumseh Sherman,
the civil war general for the US
famously said that war is hell and it's
glory is all Moonshine,
but that didn't really see into the mass
of the population is one historian had
pointed out they weren't publishing a
whole lot of combat photos and really
nasty,
terrible stuff for the folks back home
at any time during these periods.
So there wasn't a lot of stuff to really
counteract the romantic ideas of war.
This is the conflict where you can't
hide it anymore.
And even though this Belgian officer
looks at this German assault on his
photos,
something akin to the charge of the
light brigade,
the famous doomed charge of that British
cavalry during the Crimean war.
But here's the thing that this war is
going to teach.
If you watch the charge of the light
brigade and you think it's magnificent
and brave,
a doomed sort of attack on the part of
incredibly courageous men.
What happens if after the charge fails,
they send another one and the same
results occur and then they send another
one in the same results occur and then
they do it again.
And again.
At what point does this wonderful,
doomed,
romantic,
you know,
celebration of the courage of the
military heart become something obscene.
This war is going to take us there and
it's going to pound the point home until
you're sick of it.
After the failure of that German attack
on the Belgian defenses,
the Germans regroup to attack again that
same night,
August fifth,
they're waiting for the sun to go down.
And witnesses who were with the troops
described them as nervous and anxious
and gloomy about the prospects of
assaulting you know these defenses.
Again,
what's more doing it at night throughout
most of human history,
night assaults,
if you were lucky,
had torchlight illumination.
It was always a huge gamble,
very disorienting.
You couldn't see anything that was going
to change with this war and it was going
to be a facet of 20th century warfare
that we may never see repeated again.
Now that night vision has become a
battlefield staple.
There is no reason to light up the
battlefield.
In fact,
if one side has night vision and the
other doesn't,
you don't want it lit up.
In this period,
these Germans were going to go into
conflict where the nighttime darkness
could be banished by technology.
You had search lights in these forts,
knew had search lights on the German
side.
Sometimes you had shells that you could
shoot up into the air that would
illuminate the night sky and you have to
imagine bunches of those shells going
off,
you know,
at separate intervals where they overlap
and so they're getting brighter and
darker.
And it,
you know,
the look of it reminds you of like a
flash bulb flash,
that sort of strobe light,
fluorescent lumination,
and it just casts a ghostly Paul over
the whole battlefield so that every time
you get that burst of light,
you see thousands of people like ants
moving along the battlefield and you
have artillery going off.
And I mean,
just think about how weird and
disorienting being in the middle of a
modern battlefield would be in the
daytime.
And now take away the light.
It's freaky and that's what these German
soldiers are about to face.
And they're understandably nervous.
They expected some sort of romantic kind
of war.
Even if it was dangerous,
you had a chance for heroism and a
chance to die for your country.
I mean this is a generation that is
absolutely infused with the ideas of
nationalism and that dying for your
country is a huge,
glorious thing that you should look
forward to.
And now they're seeing,
wait a minute,
how glorious is it to be one of many
people mowed down by machine guns,
you know,
just sort of randomly.
They don't want to go on the assault
again and this attack starts to bog down
after it starts.
Now there's an officer who's roaming
around the battlefield who normally is
in Berlin with the high general staff of
the German military.
The Germans encourage their staff
members to get out in the field
sometimes and see what's going on,
and this guy had a particular interest
in this battle because he was one of the
people who planned it for years.
He'd been planning this battle.
He took his vacations from Germany to
Belgium just to look around where the
battle was going to be fought,
and now since he had a vested interest
in hoping his plans were carried out
correctly,
he's wandering around this battlefield
at night looking for what the holdup is
and finds out that the general
commanding a certain part of the attack
is dead killed by machine gun fire.
So this guy,
this staff officer who historians have
described as absolutely devoid of fear,
big man,
grabs the unit of the dead,
five or 6,000
men in the dark and starts leading them
toward the objective.
Now you've got all these forts,
more than 400 guns from the fort,
so then the guns on the German site,
it's just got to be this unbelievable
chaotic mess in the dark and this one
general has grabbed this unit and is and
is heading toward the city of Leon,
which is protected by this circle
affords right with men in between all
the forts.
He finds a spot that's undefended leads
this unit,
past the forts into the city on this
gamble that maybe the city won't be
defended or maybe if I walk in there
with 6,000
guys,
they'll just lay down their weapons.
Now the Germans don't have a lot to
celebrate in their military history and
the Second World War because the cause
was so nasty.
It doesn't matter.
You know how many good things their
troops did in terms of military history,
in the military side of things.
The cause is so corrupted,
taints everything.
The Germans can take some justifiable
pride in the adventure story of this guy
because first he walks in the city and
everybody just sort of surrendered to
him there and then he goes up to the
citadel,
the main defense in the center of the
city with his sword.
Hilt,
he pounds on the door demanding the
surrender,
and they open up the door and they
surrender.
Yikes.
Talk about boldness,
talk about gambling.
This is a basically unknown German
officer who,
because of the name he is making for
himself will be in a position that some
historians will call the military
dictator of Germany within four years.
Name is Eric,
gluten Dorf Luton.
Doris actions that night remind us once
again that even though,
as I've said several times,
the machines have kind of taken over the
dominant role in war,
fighting,
artillery,
guns,
all those things are machines.
You can't discount the human factor.
In fact,
the human factor is probably the
dominant factor amongst adversaries that
are somewhat evenly matched.
I mean,
no amount of military genius is going to
save Belgium from Germany.
The differences between the potential of
the two sides is just too great,
but between relatively equal or only
moderately unequal power is leadership,
could be the determining factor and the
boldness shown by Ludendorff that night
is a precursor to what we can expect
from him later on and what the Russians
can expect from him very,
very soon.
Now,
Ludin doors,
very audacious capture of the city of
Leon doesn't solve the problem that the
Germans have because all those forts are
still active.
He's taken the city,
he hasn't taken the forts and they're
still there ready to shoot up German
march columns if those,
if they're not taken before the big
march starts,
so Ludin door calls for his,
you know,
ace in the hole.
As I said,
the Germans have been planning for this
attack for a very long time.
They knew that the Belgians might resist
and they knew if they did,
they had to have a weapon that was
greater than anything.
The people who built
these forts ever envisioned in the 18
eighties,
although some of these forts dates of
the 18 nineties in that era,
the forts were basically guaranteed to
the Belgian government to be
invulnerable to any cannon then known in
the world,
but the cannons that were then known in
the world are no longer the maximum size
cannons available in the world.
Those belong to the Germans and no one
even knew it until they first showed up
on the scene and they become an even
better demonstration than the machine
gunfire.
Mowing down those board Germans charging
the Belgian defenses that the weaponry
was simply doomsday device like if you
imagine it magnified thousands of times.
The weapons that are on the way from
Germany to Belgium to reduce these forts
are the best example I can think of to
show how much has changed since the last
time.
The great powers fought each other in
Europe 100 years before and nowhere is
that more on display in evident than in
artillery,
which a hundred years ago during
Napoleon's time was already what
Napoleon thought,
decided battles,
and he was a guy who made his bones in
the artillery.
He rose through the ranks as an
artillery officer.
He's known for it's used on the
battlefield.
Here's a guy that that could shock
people with the killing power of well
used artillery and his big guns were
firing 12 pound cannonballs,
12 pound cannonballs.
The gun itself weighed about 1200
pounds.
It's the same gun essentially in in one
case that both sides in the US civil war
used,
but a 1200 pound canon.
The gun that's on its way and the guns
that are on the way from Berlin to
Belgium way the largest ways,
almost 300,000
pounds,
1200 pounds to 300,000
pounds.
The shell that Napoleon's 12 pounders
fired or between nine and 12 pounds.
The shell that this monster,
the 420 millimeter version of it that's
on the way that Shell is 2000 pounds,
the Napoleonic era cannon,
that was so deadly at the time that it
was shocking at a range of an effective
range of about 2000 yards.
This weapon on the way to Belgium,
which isn't even designed for range at
all.
It's a seed Canon,
so it doesn't even have to fire very
far,
has seven times the range of that French
cannon that was designed to shoot far.
This is an entirely new kind of warfare
and the people who actually see this gun
once it's assembled,
our slack,
jawed and assemble it must be because
think about trying to transport
this thing.
Now we're talking about a gun that is
just over a 16 inch gun,
which is the largest naval gun with the
exception of the Japanese Yamato Class.
Eighteen inch battleships ever put into
the field that the great American
battleships that Americans love to look
at from the middle to the end of the
Second World War.
Those are 16 inch guns.
These guns on the way to reduce these
forts,
are those guns basically a tiny bit
larger?
How would you transport them?
We get some giant tractor with
caterpillar,
like wheels or something wouldn't.
You didn't have any of that.
They have horses,
so they disassemble this almost 300,000
pound piece of equipment and they and
they transport it would like 35 horses
taking each piece,
you know,
and anytime there's a dip in the road,
they've got to get people to prop things
up and help him.
It takes forever and then when they get
to Belgium and the roads are all messed
up and they have to take detours,
it takes forever to get these guns to
where they need to be.
And then when they get there,
the crew and it's like a couple hundred
guys have to lay cement.
The cement has to dry,
the gun has to be assembled and put
together,
and then when they want to fire this
thing,
this gives you an idea of the monsters
were talking about the gun crew had to
go three football fields away,
300 yards away and fire the thing
electronically and they were still so
close that they had to put cotton
wadding over their eyes,
their nose and their ears,
and they had to fire this thing while
their mouth was open or they blow out
their eardrums and potentially worse
than that,
imagine what this weapon does.
The shell is fired in a 4,000
foot arch.
It takes a full minute to get from the
gun to the target,
so you fire it and then there's the 62nd
wait until the explosion happens.
Unlike Napoleon's time,
we have cool shells that can be delayed
action fused and armor piercing so that
when you fire them at these forts,
they hit the top of the fourth.
That's the kind of arc they have.
They don't fire flat.
It's something they fire way up in the
air and then it drops right on top of
these forts,
a shell that pierces armor or concrete,
and then once it reaches its maximum
depth,
then it explodes.
The wonderful world of science and
engineering is going to take over the
battlefields of this upcoming conflict
in a way that has never happened before
and this weapon to me most symbolizes in
this early part of the war.
You know your example of here's your
wakeup call.
Here's your darth vader.
Here's what 20th century warfare is
going to mean.
The gun arrives along with some cousins
were slightly smaller from the also
great armaments workshop,
Skoda in Ostrow Hungarian territory then
and the weapons created by crop and
Skoda start shelling these forts and
they start going down and they start
going down fast.
Now,
those of you who have listened
to many of my shows,
no,
I'm not a huge John Keegan fan,
but as a historian,
I think he's best on his World War One
and World War Two histories and he wrote
about this gun arrival outside.
The fordson said quote,
after it was placed,
the bombardment began the crew wearing
head padding,
lay prone 300 yards away while the gun
was fired electronically quoting
somebody hit the scene.
Now quote,
60 seconds ticked by the time needed for
the shelter traverse it's 4,000
meter trajectory,
and everyone listened in to the
telephone report of our battery
commander who had his observation post
1500 meters from the bombardment Ford
and could watch at close range the
column of smoke,
Earth and fire that climbed into the
heavens.
Keegan continues,
quote the first of the shells delay
fused to explode only after penetration
of the forge.
Protective skin fell short.
Six minutes later,
the next was fired.
Then five more.
Each of them walked up towards the
target.
As the elevation was corrected,
the relentless approaching footfall of
the detonations spoked to the paralyzed
defenders of the devastation to come.
The eighth struck home.
Then the gun fell silent for the night,
but the next morning joined by the
other,
which had completed the journey from
Essen.
The bombardment reopened,
the range had been found,
and soon the 2000 pounds shells were
quote,
stripping away armor plate and blocks of
concrete cracking arches and poisoning
the air with heavy brown fumes and quote
and Keegan then goes on to say,
no,
I'm not going to murder the poor French
names of these forts,
but at 1230,
one fort is a wreck.
He says,
and this physically incapacitated and
surrenders.
They then shift fire to another fort
which surrenders five hours later.
A third explodes when it's magazine is
hit by one of these shells completely
destroying the whole thing that will
happen to a couple of these forests by
the way,
and when they find those,
the Germans who were first on the scene
say that they look like quote,
a miniature Alpine landscape with debris
strewn about like pebbles in a mountain
stream,
heavy artillery and ammunition had been
thrown everywhere.
A cupela had been blown from its place
and had fallen on its dome and it now
looks like a monstrous tortoise lying on
its shell.
As these forts began to fall,
the artillery then closed in on the
fourth that had the general commanding
this whole affair,
and he himself wrote what it was like to
be under fire by weapons that no one had
ever seen the like of in human history,
quote,
a shell rec to the arcade under which
the general staff were sheltering.
All light was extinguished by the force
of the explosion and the officers ran
the risk of asphyxiation by the horrible
emitted from
the shell.
When the firing ceased,
I've ventured out on a tour of
inspection on the external slopes,
which I found had been reduced to a
rubble heap.
A few minutes later,
he writes,
the bombardment was resumed.
It seemed as though all the German
batteries were firing salvos.
Nobody will ever be able to form an
adequate idea of what the reality was
like.
I have only learned since that when the
big siege mortars entered into the
action,
they hurled against us shells weighing a
thousand kilos.
The explosive force of which surpassed
anything known hitherto.
Their approach was to be heard in an
acute buzzing,
and then they burst with thunderous.
Roar raising clouds of missiles,
stones and dust.
After some time passed and mid these
horrors I wished to return to my
observation tower,
but I'd hardly advanced a few feet into
the gallery when a great blast passed by
and I was thrown violently to the
ground.
I managed to get up and continued on my
way only to be stopped by a choking
clouds of poisonous gas.
It was a mixture of the gas from an
explosion and the smoke of a fire and
the troops.
Quarters,
we were driven back,
half suffocated,
looking out of a peephole.
I saw to my horror that the Ford had
fallen slopes and counter slopes being a
chaos of rubbish while huge tongues
aflame were shooting forth from the
throat of the fortress.
My first and last thought he writes was
to try to save.
The remnant of the garrison are rushed
out to give orders and saw some soldiers
who I mistook for Belgians,
gendarmes.
I called them and then fell again.
Poisonous gases.
Seemed to grip my throat as an
face end quote.
He woke up to one of his aides and the
German officer giving him water.
Those soldiers he thought were Belgian
were German and they were the first to
enter the fort after a shell detonated,
you know the magazine and the entire
fort went up in a giant explosion.
These are enormous metal and steel and
concrete,
you know,
forts.
These guns were pulverizing forts that
were built to withstand the guns of just
a generation before and doing so with
ease.
That's a demonstration of how much
things had changed just since the 18
eighties and think of how much things
had changed from Napoleon's time to the
18 eighties.
This was a 19th century world
discovering the horrors of 20th century
warfare and they were going to have to
learn how to deal with this new reality.
One horrific bloody lesson at a time.
The lesson of leakage is at the era's of
basing your defenses on fortes is over.
This is a lesson that will not be
learned and will be taught again in
France in May 19,
40.
It's also my opinion that the Germans
are being taught a lesson.
Even as this story's going down and the
guns are pulverizing,
the Fortune Belgium,
the Germans should be picking up on what
you know,
current events or trying to teach them.
They will never take that lesson to
heart and they will repeat these
mistakes that they're making in Belgium.
Again,
in the Second World War.
It's safe to say I think that the damage
done to the German reputation globally
because of what's going on in Belgium
won't go away until at least the 19
fifties and I think you could make a
very decent case.
I've never gone away and it involves
German treatment of neutral countries
and noncombatants wherever they find
them.
And you know,
as you watch this story unfold,
it's clear that in some respects the
Germans just don't get it when you would
think they would.
This is a country that in.
It's funny now they've lost this
reputation due to two world wars and
their involvement in both of them,
but they used to be considered an
absolute hotbed of human culture.
You know,
the cutting edge of art and science and
literature and thought and philosophy.
I mean all these things that the Germans
really prided themselves in music,
I mean an incredible people that guys
like hg wells were intimidated by,
couldn't help admire them,
but was intimidated by how,
how ahead of things.
They seem to be at how advanced Asian to
be in all these areas.
How strangely ironic though that people
that are so advanced in those areas
could have so many blind spots in areas
that one would think are related to the
higher culture aspects.
Do the people who are producing such
cutting edge higher culture,
how did they miss something that's
likely to be as damaging to your
international reputation as what history
now calls the rape of Belgium?
Now the rape of Belgium,
I should point out a little bit,
is a propagandists fantasy.
I mean they've made it into practically
a movie.
The rape of Belgium.
Go see the rape of Dan King in your
history books and then you will see
something that propagandists did not
need to magnify it all to create a world
class historical atrocity killing field.
Belgium wasn't that,
but it was something and that something
would come back to haunt the Germans in
ways that they almost seem ignorant of
again.
We quoted Hitler earlier about
propaganda.
Hitler sees it after the war.
The Germans were just blindsided by 20th
century global communications and the
ability to manipulate world opinion by
taking things that were real facts and
blowing them up to levels that just
incensed whole societies,
including countries.
The Germans don't understand that the
way they're conducting themselves in
Belgium is affecting public opinion in
places like the United States,
which have large German American
populations by the way,
which are cheering,
you know,
the the feats of arms and how the German
military is showing themselves to be so
dominant.
American papers are not 100 percent
against the Germans at this point.
In some places.
American papers are in regions that are
dominated by German Americans,
but they can't explain away what's
happening in Belgium and what starts the
day.
The invasion of Belgium happens.
The Germans start killing Belgian
citizens and they do so as part of what
is now understood to be a policy of
fruitfulness.
As it was called,
I'm not sure that's the perfect
translation of the term,
but the Germans intended to,
you know,
set examples of people that did things
that the Germans had said you shouldn't
do.
They said you shouldn't blow up bridges.
If they find you blowing up bridges,
they are going to punish you and they do
not give probation.
They will hang you.
They will shoot you if they catch you
trying to blow up a bridge.
The Germans take that even farther
though.
If you're near a village,
we're a bridge,
gets blown up.
The village might pay the price.
The Germans believed in collective
punishment.
They also believed in taking hostages
for good behavior and when people did
stuff anyway,
they killed the hostages.
This has been one of the most
contentious parts of,
you know,
new scholarship all the time on the
question of atrocities in Belgium
because,
you know,
during the war it is this huge deal and
those of you,
by the way,
who've lived long enough to have seen
this same dynamic at work were real
atrocities happened.
I remember in the first Gulf War,
the stories of,
you know,
Iraqi soldiers taking Kuwaiti babies out
of incubators and throwing them on the
floor and then stealing the incubators
and all these stories are normal because
real atrocities are going on,
but then they're magnified because the
magnification works to the benefit of
the enemies of the people.
The propaganda's working against the
Germans went in and did a bunch of
things in Belgium that make them look
bad because they were bad,
and then the foreign media like the
British were fantastic at this.
Get Ahold of those stories and turn them
into the worst things you can ever think
of.
The Germans only began to get this,
you know,
a few people at a time.
I mean later on,
much later on,
the Kaiser's Sonnet guy known as the
crown prince would say that Belgium's
when the Germans lost the first great
battle of the war,
but they didn't lose it on the
battlefield.
They crushed the Belgians.
They lost it in the realm of global
public opinion because of their behavior
behavior that the Germans will use all
throughout this war.
And again,
in the Second World War,
this tendency to ignore neutrality,
and as we said earlier,
the German diplomat,
you know,
told the British diplomat this,
you're going to go to war over a piece
of paper.
It's just a piece of neutrality is often
violated in war.
That's kind of how they thought.
They also thought that you treat
noncombatants harshly and you know,
to sort of soften that a little.
It's worth noting that the Germans treat
their own people this way.
They are a stern rather strict.
Some would say severe society
especially,
you know,
the Prussian ised elements of it.
And they expect,
you know,
obedience and discipline and conformity
to the rules and that's what they expect
of their own people.
And then they go into Belgium and when
people violate the rules,
they get treated harshly.
Germans just failed to foresee maybe
with cultural blinders that people that
come from much less severe traditions
would maybe play that quality up as
something uniquely German and Nasty.
Not just that.
It should be pointed out that a lot of
different people's,
you know,
in the world at this time,
we're having problems dealing with
irregular fighting.
This was a big deal at the time.
Irregular fighting of course,
is when,
you know,
regular people take up arms and starts
shooting at your soldiers like guerrilla
troops.
For example,
in Vietnam,
the US fought Viet Cong guerrillas,
very difficult to do causes all kinds of
problems.
Atrocities tend to happen.
Uh,
the British had just dealt with this,
not all together successfully in South
Africa where atrocity issues happened.
The French were dealing with it in Asia
and North Africa.
The Russians were dealing with it in
central Asia.
The Japanese were dealing with it in
China and Korea.
This is a problem a lot of countries
were having.
The Germans were very worried about what
were called free shooters today we would
call them snipers because in the war of
1870,
they had a lot of problems with snipers.
So they went into Belgium and if they
thought snipers were there,
people paid the price left,
right.
And Center,
I mean,
whole towns would be executed if a
sniper was loose.
And here's the worst part.
Snipers may not have even been loosed.
Some historians say these are a bunch of
gun shy soldiers who've never faced,
you know,
live fire where someone was shooting at
them.
They may hear some German soldiers gun
go off from the other side of town and
start killing civilians.
It's a very controversial issue.
Some historians still foam at the mouth
about A.
John Keegan strikes me as somebody
who's,
who feels this absolute need to defend
this idea of German,
you know,
uh,
devilishly this.
I have a couple of pieces I liked
though.
Author Lynn Mcdonald wrote about this.
I thought she did a very balanced job.
And so did Neil Ferguson and Ferguson.
What I love about Ferguson says he goes
and finds like the regional thing that
happened and then how it got blown out
of proportion.
And,
but nonetheless,
all these people emphasize the same
thing.
These atrocities happen.
These people die.
The Germans practiced collective
punishment,
all these awful things that most,
uh,
most of us reviled today.
And then they paid an extra price for it
by providing the basic seeds that would
grow into enemy propaganda that would
turn the Germans into Genghis Khan
basically,
which is exactly what Lynn Mcdonald
compares it to,
and she writes,
quote in the United Kingdom,
Germany's on had already been tried and
found guilty.
Germany's name was mud,
and now that she had condemned herself
out of her own mouth,
no rumor of Beast Gel outrage was two
vial to be believed.
They emanated mainly from the refugees
who had fled half terrified out of their
wits from the towns and villages of
Belgium.
They were the firsthand accounts from
people who had escaped from the flames
of Van den,
where 200 hostages had been shot from
two means.
We're 400 were gunned down and bayoneted
and from the inhabitants of not who
would arouse the ire of the Germans by
destroying the vital bridge,
the Germans revenge was to round up more
than 600 men,
women and children,
and shoot them in cold blood.
The youngest age,
three weeks died in his mother's arms.
These stories were true and the Germans
made no attempt to keep them secret.
They were after all intended to warn.
Inevitably,
as they traveled,
they spawned fictions in their wake of
rape,
of Macabre chillings,
of mutilation,
of breasts and hands,
sliced off by sabers of crucifixions,
of babies dipped into boiling water or
swung for sport against brick walls.
There were even whispers of cannibalism.
Grains of truth swelled and grew into a
crop of rumors of unspeakable.
Villainy is unsurpassed since the hordes
of Genghis Khan had rampaged and
pillaged across Asia,
in France and in Britain.
The newspapers were full of them.
Public opinion hardened.
It was no longer merely adjust war.
It was positively righteous and people
were out for blood and quote.
I don't think the Germans have recovered
from that image.
Even now,
have they?
You talk about a misstep.
What if the Germans had treated neutral
countries and noncombatants with more
respect?
How different might their reputation be
today?
What if they'd learned from Belgium in
1914 and reacted differently in 1939?
One thing's for sure,
this whole idea of rightfulness in order
to cow.
You know,
the people that you had just subjected
to the boots of your soldiers that
didn't work out bad policy foundations
and the underpinnings of that idea.
It just didn't work.
And the people in charge of it were guys
like von Moltke who said know to his
Austrian counterpart.
Yeah,
you know,
it's brutal.
Are advanced into Belgium is brutal,
but what are you going to do?
You know,
we're fighting to save our lives.
Basically,
this is life or death.
It's going to be a little brutal for
awhile.
And guys like von Moltke,
he was one of these logical insanity
guys.
Somebody asked him once,
um,
you know,
what the humane way to carry out war is?
And he famously said,
make it quick.
Brutal as you want.
Make it quick.
It's our old boxing analogy of on
multiple was basically saying,
knock him out quick knockouts.
That's the nicest you can be,
even if it's horribly brutal to make the
knockout as quick as it is.
So von Moltke in this case is basically
saying,
you know,
yeah,
it's a,
it's terrible.
But,
uh,
you know,
in the end this is going to save lives,
you,
you hang a few of these saboteurs,
uh,
you shoot a few of these people that
snipe at your troops and then they
stopped doing it and you don't have to
burn whole villages down.
See how that works.
Neil Ferguson,
when he addresses this issue is
basically sort of telling us to not be
so naive and we've all lived through,
you know,
we're in the 21st century now.
We've had a long time to absorb the
ideas of 20th century propaganda and how
it's a legitimate aspect of war.
And one of the things you do is perhaps
paint your adversary in the worst
possible light you can.
Again,
something that the Germans weren't quite
getting when the 20th century was brand
new,
that they would get much better in the
second world war.
Ferguson in his book,
tells a story where he talks about,
you know,
the ways in which this propaganda were
used when he talks about how the British
newspapers would take photos sometimes
from stories that had nothing to do with
this war.
And one case stories with that had
photos from Russian pogroms against Jews
that happened before the war.
And then just,
you know,
captioning the photo with something that
says it's from this war.
I mean no one had any idea,
show a bunch of dead civilians and say,
this is what the Germans are doing.
Ferguson writes quote,
but prewar photographs of Russian
pogroms genuinely were reprinted to,
in quotes,
illustrate stories of German behavior in
Belgium.
The Sunday chronicle he writes,
was one of many British papers which
alleged that the Germans had cut off the
hands of Belgian children while the
former scaremonger William luck who
related with ill disguised relish the
quote wild orgies of blood and
debauchery and quote in which the
Germans allegedly indulged,
including the quote,
ruthless violation and killing of
defenseless women.
Girls and children of tender age and
quote Ferguson continues quote other
writers had great fun imagining.
Sixteen year old girls being quote,
forced to drink and quote unquote
violated successively and quote on the
lawn before having their breasts pierced
with bayonets.
And quote the bayoneted baby Ferguson
says was another favorite image.
J H Morgan even threw in the charge of
sodomy,
have little children and quote,
but even Ferguson is forced to deal with
the reality of the situation that this
stuff wasn't manufactured out of whole
cloth and that being a Belgium in the
line of German advance during this time
period was a very dangerous position to
perhaps find yourself in and perhaps of
no fault of your own Ferguson writes
quote,
although the Entente press wildly
exaggerated what went on in Belgium.
There is no question that the German
army did commit atrocities there in
1914.
According to evidence from the diaries
of German soldiers and other reliable
sources,
all the advancing German armies executed
civilians,
including women and priests altogether,
about 5,500
Belgian civilians were deliberately
killed by the German army.
Most of them in the 11 day period from
the 18th to the 28th of August,
1914 and at least another 500 in France.
The Germans also used civilians as human
shields and raised numerous villages to
the ground.
In one case,
an 18 year old girl was bayoneted to
death.
There were also numerous rapes in
occupied France and quote John Keegan,
who obviously feels very strongly about
this,
um,
goes out of his way to point out that
these are not,
you know,
sort of ramshackle affairs,
that these involve lots of troops
sometimes that these executions are not
done by special execution squads is,
will be the case in the Second World War
sometimes,
but by regular units that the German
army,
he writes,
quote,
the victims included children and women
as well as men and the killings were
systematic at 10 means the hostages were
masked in the square,
shot down by execution squads and
survivors,
Bay and edit.
The execution.
Squads were not as where the action
groups of Hitler's Holocaust,
especially recruited killers,
but ordinary German soldiers.
Indeed those who murdered at end den
where the reservists of the most
distinguished regimens of the Prussian
army,
the guard regimen mentors,
will end quote and the Belgians would
have every right.
You would think when you to wonder as
they're living through this,
where their protectors are.
Now they signed these agreements that
said that their independence was
guaranteed by the greatest powers of the
age.
Where are those people right now?
When the Belgians need them?
All they see are the German army
marching through and burning things and
perhaps shooting people you know.
The answer is they're on the way.
The British are in the process,
right as we are in this story of landing
troops on the continent to aid the
French who are finishing the last bits
of the necessary ingredients so they can
launch an offensive.
The Russians are shocking everybody by
putting together enough units to at
least attack eastern Germany and remind
the German that you can't just leave
your eastern border undefended and throw
everything against France.
We're still here
and the ostrow Hungarians are about to
find out exactly why the Serbs have such
a ferocious military reputation.
All this is going to happen pretty much
simultaneously and it's going to be the
first real consequential experiment to
test a hypothesis,
a sort of celeste deal,
if you want,
or cosmic hypothesis concerning the
question of whether or not know if you
do it enough.
You can beat the violence out of a
society or a culture or people or maybe
given the globalization.
You know that this time period helps
usher in maybe a world,
and the answer is that it depends on how
hard you beat them.
I guess no one's been beaten very hard
yet in this story.
The Belgians are,
but an appetizer to what modern warfare
is going to be like.
Modern warfare between the great powers
on the planet.
The first experiment in this hypothesis
of beating the violence out of societies
is on the way.
If there's an addiction to the human
species,
what's about to happen is the first dose
of shock therapy to see if we can be
curative.
It
be sure to follow us on twitter.
The address is at hardcore history.
Do you want to help the podcast?
We'd really appreciate it.
Here's how it works.
It's very simple just by your Amazon.com
products through the Amazon search
window on Dan Carlin Dot com and Dan and
Ben will get a percentage of what you
spend and it helps these guys out
because they are nice young fellows.
If you think the show you just heard is
worth a dollar,
Dan and Ben would love to have it.
A buck a show.
It's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.
Get their firstest with the most.
I think that's the phrase that made me
cringe during the editing process.
Listening to the show you just heard
because I could almost hear a five,
10,
15,000.
I don't know how many avid civil war
buffs,
American civil war buffs.
We have listening,
but that's going to be a sore point with
them and I could tell when I listened to
it during editing,
I'm just going,
Ugh,
do I really want all those emails?
I didn't attribute that quote to anyone
I just said a confederate cavalry
commander,
but it was supposedly allegedly
legendarily said by a guy named Nathan
Bedford forrest.
A controversial figure even today,
but that's not unusual among confederate
generals and it's not even unheard of
among union northern generals.
Forest is maybe in a class by himself,
but he's not controversial when it comes
to acknowledging his military genius.
He's one of the best American generals
in this whole period in us history and
he's an innovative cavalry commander.
He knows and has already absorbed the
lesson that most European cavalry
commanders,
even in the first world war when it
breaks out that they haven't absorbed
yet,
forest realizes that you can't use
cavalry the way it's traditionally been
used.
You know,
through its entire history.
Up until that point,
it's just too vulnerable.
Now.
The weapons had destroyed a lot of what
cavalry could do,
so forest stripped down the job of
cavalry to the bare minimum.
What does it do that nothing else can
do,
and it moves people faster than anything
else can.
So we used it for that.
He essentially had an elite unit of
mounted infantry and he would transport
these people too vulnerable and
important spots,
tactically important areas,
dismount them and use them as infantry
and then use the horses to skedaddle out
of there before superior force could
catch you.
It's a very modern way to use cavalry
and really the only way that it could
survive on a modern battlefield.
Of course,
the battlefield that Nathan Bedford
forrest was trying to keep his cavalry
live on nowhere near as deadly for
anyone horses,
especially as the battlefields would be
in 1914.
Those battlefields or on the way the
appetizers over the main course is about
to begin this greatest army in the world
is about to run into what is probably
the second greatest army in the world,
Francis and the probably in terms of
bang for their buck.
Most elite military force,
most experienced military force in the
world.
All these Germans marching on France,
great train troops who've never been in
combat except against Belgians.
They're going to run into a British
colonial force that's tiny,
but that has so much experience that
there's almost no room for any more unit
owners for these units because they
fought in so many parts of the world so
long and so often they are not coming to
this war.
You know,
to learn on the job.
They've already done this job.
Many times they're going to be the only
truly,
really experienced troops in this
conflict which will make them to get
back to our boxing metaphors.
Able to punch above their weight class,
they're going to give a lot better than
their small numbers.
Probably indicate they would McCann
anything stopped this German steam
roller,
you know,
I've often been asked by people how
large the army that defended imperial
Rome was and at its height,
the high number,
you usually see a 750,000
men.
So the entire Roman empire,
that's not one arm you with the entire
Roman empires know total number of
soldiers throughout the entire,
you know,
borders and interior of the places.
Maybe 750,000
guys.
Seven hundred and 50,000
guys is also the upper limit number as
we said in the show that Napoleon may
have used in his famous and for Lauren
invasion of Russia.
So that's a pretty big number just to
understand what's bearing down on the
small British force that's landed on the
continent and this French force who's
waiting to find out what modern warfare
is really like.
The low number is 750,000
Germans just simply marching through
Belgium.
The high number is one point $5 million,
and that doesn't even count the troops
facing the French along the traditional
fortified hundred and 20 mile border.
That's normally the invasion route.
You have the equivalent of the entire
armed power of the Roman Empire at its
height using the Belgian road systems to
fall on northeastern France.
That's an amazing blow.
What happens when the irresistible force
in a runs into the immovable object?
Well,
we'll find out if either one of those
titles turns out to be true in part to a
blueprint for Armageddon.